Herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und heute in der 33. Ausgabe von unserer Gesprächsreihe wollen wir mal einen interessanten Bogen schlagen aus der Raumfahrt auf Problemstellungen hier auf der Erde, die so ein bisschen auch in der Raumfahrt teilweise ihren Anfang genommen haben und wo die Raumfahrt auch heute noch auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise eingebunden ist. Konkret geht es hier um Szenarien für eine nachhaltige Energieversorgung in der Zukunft und in gewisser Hinsicht auch in der Gegenwart. Und dazu bin ich nach Stuttgart gefahren zum DLR-Standort hier in Feingen und begrüße als Gesprächspartner Franz Strieb. Du bist Wissenschaftler im Institut für technische Thermodynamik. Warum muss man da noch technisch davor schreiben?
Naja, das ist so der Name, unter dem wir laufen. Das ist unser Label seit Jahrzehnten und den wollen wir auch gar nicht ändern.
Okay, aber es geht auf jeden Fall um Thermodynamik unter anderem. Das ist ja ein komplexer physikalischer Begriff. Was wird unter diesem Thema hier alles zusammengefasst in dem Institut?
Ja, letztendlich hat das mit Energie zu tun. Es geht um Energieversorgung, Energieerstellung, Bereitstellung von Energieformen, um die Speicherung von Energie, um die Umwandlung von Energie. Da spielt die Thermodynamik dann immer eine Rolle, weil es Verluste gibt, die durch die Thermodynamik dann ganz gut beschrieben werden.
Aber im weiteren Sinne geht es hier um Energiegewinnungsforschung.
Gewinnung, Erstellung, Versorgung, Speicherung.
Ist das so das Thema des gesamten Standorts hier?
Nein, der gesamte Standort hat noch andere Institute, Materialforschung, Fahrzeugkonzepte. Da werden moderne Fahrzeugkonzepte entwickelt. Leichtbau von Fahrzeugen zum Beispiel. Da gibt es auch Synergien zwischen den Instituten, eben Materialforschung, Fahrzeugkonzepte, Antriebe aus Brennstoffzellen, die Wasserstoff verwenden, auch Stromantriebe, letztendlich Batterien. All diese Sachen werden hier erforscht. Dann auch Antriebe, die mit Gas funktionieren, Gas-Turbinen, Verbrennungsforschung oder auch Sachen wie Laserforschung in der technischen Physik. Also verschiedene Institute mit ganz verschiedenen Themen, die manchmal auch mit der Raumfahrt zu tun haben. Also Optimierung von Teilen für die Raumfahrt oder auch für die Luftfahrt. Darum geht es. Und eben auch die Verbrennung von Brennstoffen als Antrieb für Energieerzeugung oder eben auch für Fahrzeuge oder auch für Flugzeuge und Raketen.
Das heißt, da ergeben sich dann auch regelmäßig so Synergieeffekte aus diesen ganzen benachbarten Instituten?
Genau, da ergeben sich Synergien, die arbeiten da auch zusammen. Auch natürlich mit allen anderen Instituten im DLR, also über Deutschland hinweg und sogar weltweit teilweise. Wir arbeiten zum Beispiel im Institut dann mit Spanien zusammen. Wir entwickeln hier Komponenten von solarthermischen Kraftwerken, zum Beispiel die Sonnenenergie in Elektrizität umwandeln. Und da hier bei uns eben wenig die Sonne scheint und in Spanien mehr, haben wir dort eine Niederlassung, in der wir dann solche Anlagen testen, in der Sonne, im Realbetrieb. Das können wir hier dann weniger machen. Machen sie aber sogar auch hier in Deutschland, in Jülich zum Beispiel, beim Kraftwerk.
Der ganze Standort ist ja hier eingebettet, so in den universitären Bereich hier, an der Universität Stuttgart. Aber hier gibt es auch, glaube ich, noch so einige andere akademisch orientierte Unternehmen. Ist man dann hier auch im größeren Verbund?
Ja, natürlich. Da gibt es auch Zusammenarbeit teilweise, auch Kontakte. Unser Institutsleiter war ja auch gleichzeitig Leiter eines Universitätsinstituts. Da gibt es natürlich auch Zusammenarbeit, aber eben nicht nur hier mit Stuttgart oder mit dem Standort, sondern eigentlich deutschlandweit, europaweit haben wir Kontakte und letztendlich sogar weltweit. Weil das Energiethema natürlich wirklich ein globales Thema inzwischen ist und auch weltweit bearbeitet werden muss.
Im Mittelpunkt soll aber heute die Energieversorgung stehen. Da muss man jetzt nicht groß ausholen, um klarzumachen, dass das natürlich ein heißes globales Thema ist. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Klimawandel und viele andere Zwänge erfordern dort neue Konzepte, die ja auch schon seit Längerem verfolgt werden. Aber so die Raumfahrt hatte ja das Problem eigentlich schon noch viel früher.
Ja, es ging ja immer schon darum, Fahrzeuge, die ins Weltall fliegen, mit Energie zu versorgen. Und die Energiequelle, die da nahe liegt, ist natürlich die Sonnenergie. Es wurde daraus die Photovoltaik zum Beispiel entwickelt, kommt aus der Raumfahrt. Es wurden sogar solathermische Kraftwerke, also thermodynamische Kreisläufe entwickelt, die Raumstation vielleicht auf dem Mond oder auf dem Mars mal mit Energie versorgen, die auch die Sonnenenergie nutzen, um einen thermodynamischen Kreislauf, wie ein Motor oder eine Dampfturbine oder eine Gasturbine zu betreiben. Auf dem Mond? Auf dem Mond und auf dem Mars, ja genau. Es sind einfach, steckt man Wärme rein und mechanische Energie kommt raus, die man dann eben in Elektrizität umwandeln kann, um so eine Versorgung zu gewährleisten. Da gab es sehr frühe Ansätze, so etwas zu machen. Man hat natürlich dann irgendwann gemerkt, so etwas geht auf der Erde auch. Und letztendlich kommen daraus die Technologien, die Solarenergie nutzen, die wir heute zur Verfügung haben.
Von was für einem irgendwann reden wir an der Stelle?
So 60er Jahre, ich glaube die Ideen, wer weiß wie alt die sind, die sind schon sehr, sehr alt. Also vielleicht schon 100 Jahre Visionäre hatten solche Ideen schon vor 100 Jahren wahrscheinlich. Und zum Beispiel, ganz witzig, das erste solathermische Kraftwerk, was Sonnenenergie, Sonnenlicht konzentriert hat, damit eine hohe Temperatur erzeugt hat und Dampf erzeugt hat zum Antrieb einer Maschine, hat 100-jähriges Jubiläum dieses Jahr, die hat in Ägypten gestanden und hat Wasser gepumpt aus dem Boden heraus auf die Felder dort. Das hat ein Frank Truman erfunden. Das war letztendlich eine Dampfmaschine, die mit Sonnenenergie funktioniert hat. Frank Truman hatte sogar die Vision, einmal mit dieser Technologie Strom zu erzeugen und diesen Strom nach Europa zu transportieren. Das Ding ist 100 Jahre alt. Das war 1910, 12, so rum. Hat 100-jähriges Jubiläum.
Das geht, glaube ich, ganz gut unter Visionär in die Bücher.
Heute laufen solche Kraftwerke im großen Maßstab in den USA und in Spanien und auch jetzt wieder in Nordafrika, wo wir schon ein paar Prototypen genau dieser Technologie jetzt laufen haben, die Strom erzeugen.
Bleiben wir vielleicht noch kurz bei den ursprünglichen Entwicklungen der Raumfahrt. Solartechnik ist im Wesentlichen in der Raumfahrt zunächst einmal vorangetrieben worden.
Ja, also Photovoltaik zur Versorgung von Satelliten war schon von Anfang an Teil der Raumfahrttechnologie. Und irgendwann wurde sie so kostengünstig, dass man dran gedacht hat, sie auf die Erde zu bringen. Dann gab es natürlich die Ölpreiskrise in den 70er Jahren. Da fing das dann an, wirklich diese Systeme auch für die Erde fit zu machen. Und das hat dann auch stattgefunden. Und dann wurden sie im großen Maßstab hergestellt. Dann wurde die Technologie eben für die Bedingungen auf der Erde weiterentwickelt, für die Robustheit, die so ein Betrieb dann erfordert. Na ja, und inzwischen gibt es das halt. Wir haben etwa 70.000 Megawatt installierte Leistung Photovoltaik heute auf der Welt. 70 Gigawatt. Und von den konzentrierenden solarthermischen Kraftwerken, also diesen solarbetriebenen Dampfkraftwerken, haben wir so etwa 2 Gigawatt heute installiert. Oder auch zum Teil noch im Bau vielleicht.
Kann man das mal so in Relation setzen zu den anderen Kraftwerkerzeugern?
Ja, Windenergie haben wir auch schon so 270, glaube ich, oder 250 Gigawatt weltweit installiert. Das ist auch schon eine ganze Menge. Insgesamt dürften weltweit so etwa 4000 Gigawatt installierte Leistung sein. Wasserkraft dann auch eben und die fossilen Energien und die Kernenergie insgesamt. Größenordnung 4000 Gigawatt, würde ich mal sagen.
Was so insgesamt eine Energieerzeugung auf diesem Planeten wirkt?
Die installierte Leistung, die Strom erzeugt. Was ganz interessant ist, es wurden letztes Jahr so etwa 200 Gigawatt Leistung neu zugebaut. Das ist so, was im Jahr weltweit zugebaut wird. Und die Hälfte davon war erneuerbar. Also Wasserkraft, Windenergie und Photovoltaik im Wesentlichen. Aber dann auch Biomasse, solarthermische Kraftwerke, das eine oder andere geothermische Kraftwerk auch, das die Erdwärme nutzt und so weiter. Also das ist schon die Hälfte der jährlich zugebauten Leistung ist erneuerbar heute. Es gibt noch eine ganze Zeit, bis man jetzt den Status fossiler Energie erreicht hat, insgesamt kumuliert, aber ja, ist doch schon gut. Die Hälfte ist erneuerbar.
Man hat auch so den Eindruck, dass die ganzen erneuerbaren Energien größere Fortschritte machen, als das so in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung angekommen ist.
Ja, absolut. Ja, also wie gesagt, die Hälfte der weltweit installierten Leistung ist erneuerbar. Da kann man sich erst mal gar nicht beschweren. Was noch nicht angekommen ist, ist die dezidierte politische Entscheidung, das jetzt wirklich konsequent weiterzumachen, das durchzuziehen, weil das ist notwendig. Aus Umweltgründen, Klimawandel haben wir ja angesprochen, aber letztendlich auch aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen. Wir hatten in den letzten zehn Jahren eine Brennstoffkostensteigerung für Kohle, Öl und Gas von 15 Prozent pro Jahr. Also in den zehn Jahren eine Vervierfachung der Brennstoffkosten. Und das scheint so weiterzugehen ungebremst. Und wenn wir davon abkommen wollen, brauchen wir erneuerbare Energien. Das ist eigentlich der Hauptgrund für mich, um erneuerbare Energien zu etablieren, ein wirtschaftlicher. Das ist ein stabilisierendes Element unserer Energieversorgung. Das liegt daran, dass eben erneuerbare Energien hauptsächlich Kapitalgüter sind. Da wird nichts verbrannt und verbraucht, sondern das sind Kapitalgüter, Investitionsgüter. Die muss ich einmal hinstellen und dann produzieren sie Strom. Das heißt, die Kosten für diesen Strom sind auch konstant über die Lebensdauer eines solchen Kraftwerks. Egal, ob Windenergie, Photovoltaik oder ein solathermisches Kraftwerk, die Kosten sind praktisch Kapitalkosten. Dann zahlen sie einen Kredit zurück. Das sind konstante Kosten. Sie haben noch Personal, auch das ist relativ konstant, während Energieerzeugung auf der Basis von Brennstoffen jedes Jahr teurer wird. Und wenn wir davon runterkommen wollen, bleibt uns gar nichts anderes als erneuerbare Energien. Und zudem dadurch, dass wir immer mehr erneuerbare Energie installieren, haben wir Skaleneffekte, also sozusagen Massenproduktion, wir haben ja Konkurrenz auf den Märkten. Und diese Technologien werden jedes Jahr billiger, also kostengünstiger. Auch dies ist natürlich ein kostenstabilisierendes Element. Je mehr wir davon zubauen, desto günstiger wird die Versorgung. Bei Brennstoffen ist es genau andersrum. Je mehr wir die brauchen, desto teurer werden sie. Und ich denke, erneuerbare muss man machen aus ökonomischen Gründen.
Damit kommen wir wieder zurück hier konkret auf die Arbeit, die hier an dem Institut geleistet wird. Und auch das, was hier im Mittelpunkt deiner Tätigkeit steht. Was ist eigentlich dein persönlicher Hintergrund und Werdegang, der dich hierher geführt hat?
Ich habe angefangen, Maschinenbau zu studieren in Clausthal-Zellerfeld. Ich bin Maschinenbauingenieur, Verfahrenstechnik. Und dort hatte ich die erste Vorlesung über erneuerbare Energien. Das war eine sehr schöne, übergreifende Vorlesung, die alle erneuerbaren Energieformen mal vorgestellt hat, den Studenten. Wann war das? Das war so in den 80ern. Und das Thema hat mich sofort begeistert. Und seitdem bin ich da dran. Seit Mitte der 80er Jahre bin ich an den Erneuerbaren dran, erst als Student. Dann habe ich noch promoviert an der Universität Oldenburg. Dort haben wir ein Energielabor gehabt, in dem man praktisch ein autonomes, erneuerbares Energiesystem testen konnte. Dort habe ich dann einen Wasserstoffspeicher für die Langzeitspeicherung von Wind- und Photovoltaikenergie aufbauen dürfen als Doktorarbeit. Das hat auch funktioniert. Und danach durfte ich dann an eine Universität in Peru als Hochschullehrer gehen, direkt aus der Doktorarbeit heraus, wo ich Hochschullehrerin habe, Professoren an der Universität unterrichtet. Das war natürlich eine ganz spannende Zeit.
Auch in dem Thema?
Erneuerbare Energien, ja. Das war ein Postgraduate-Course sozusagen für Erneuerbare Energien. Und ich habe dann den Professoren an der Uni beigebracht, was Erneuerbare Energien sind. Das war total spannend, weil ich musste das ja auch in dem Stil dann aufarbeiten, sozusagen, dass das dafür verwendet werden kann, also für Vorlesungen und Material. Das war schon eine tolle Herausforderung. Ja, und danach bin ich dann beim DLR hier, nach zwei Jahren Peru, bin ich dann hier zum DLR gekommen, habe mich hier gewohnt.
Ich mache mal die Erfahrung, dass wenn man anderen Leuten erklären muss, das ist eigentlich noch der Extremfall, wenn man es anderen Leuten erklären muss, sodass ihr das selber extrem ist, dass dabei der eigentliche, der eigene Lerneffekt nochmal besonders stark ist.
Ja, also ich sollte denen damals was beibringen. Dabei habe ich gelernt, dass ich viel mehr gelernt habe als sie in der Zeit. Das ist genau der Punkt. Man lernt bei sowas sehr viel. Und das ist natürlich sehr schön. Man lernt was über das Land. Man lernt was über sich selbst und über das Thema, an dem man arbeitet, lernt man auch eine ganze Menge.
Ja, jetzt findet ja schon eine ganze Menge Entwicklung statt. Es gibt ja auch seit einigen Jahren schon eine recht lebendige Industrielandschaft, die sich mit Solar und vielen anderen erneuerbaren Technologien auseinandersetzt. Inwieweit ist denn da jetzt noch das DLR überhaupt gefragt, da mitzumischen? Geht das nicht von alleine?
Ja gut, eine Technologie, wenn sie kommerziell ist, dann endlich ist sie ja noch lange nicht perfekt. Und es gibt immer weiter Forschungsbedarf, Optimierungsbedarf, Wirkungsgrade können verbessert werden, die Kosten können gesenkt werden. Das sind ja so wichtige Themen bei der Forschung, gerade für erneuerbare Energien, weil die eben hauptsächlich aus Kapitalkosten bestehen. Und diese Kapitalkosten senken ist eines der Forschungsgebiete letztendlich. Ein ganz wichtiger Punkt bei Sonnenenergie ist die Speicherung von Sonnenenergie. Sonnenenergie kommt ja nur oder ist nur verfügbar, wenn die Sonne scheint. Und unser Strombedarf ist zum Beispiel nachts am höchsten oder in den frühen Abendstunden. Das passt nicht zusammen. Und da muss man natürlich von Zeitpunkt A, wo die Sonne scheint, zum Zeitpunkt B, wo man den Strom braucht, irgendwie speichern können. Und solche Sachen sind noch am Anfang, funktionieren zwar schon, aber haben noch ein sehr, sehr großes Potential, besser zu werden und günstiger zu werden. Und daran forscht letztendlich auch das DLR. Also auch hier im Institut Speicherforschung ist ein wichtiger Bereich hier im Institut, um dieses Thema weiter zu perfektionieren und weiter zu treiben. Und das öffnet natürlich dann auch wieder Anwendungsmöglichkeiten für letztendlich die Erzeugungstechnologien, die unbedingt Speicher brauchen, weil sonst haben sie irgendwo eine Grenze, wo sie eingesetzt werden können.
Was steht denn da jetzt so im Mittelpunkt? Wir haben ja jetzt schon ein paar Begriffe genannt. Vielleicht sollten wir das technisch auch mal ein bisschen auseinanderhalten. Also Photovoltaik ist das, was halt primär bei den Satelliten am Anfang zum Einsatz kam oder ist vielleicht auch das Einzige, was da oben zum Einsatz kommt.
Ja, letztendlich, ja.
Kennt man eben Solarpanele, was findet da konkret statt?
Naja, das sind praktisch Konverter, die direkt durch einen Halbleiter-Effekt Sonnenlicht in Strom umwandeln. Das ist ein Halbleiter-Effekt. Ja, da muss man die Quantenphysik bemühen. Da werden sozusagen verschiedene Energieniveaus angeregt, die Elektronen auf ein anderes Energieniveau zum Fließen bringen. Und letztendlich, wenn man an die Solarzelle eine elektrische Last anschließt über Leitungen, kann dieser Strom fließen, um das Energieniveau wieder auszugleichen. Der Clou von der Photovoltaik ist, dass direkt Strom erzeugt wird. Es gibt eben kein Dampfkraftwerk dazwischen wie beim Kohlekraftwerk, beim Kernkraftwerk oder bei der Gas-Turbine, wo erst mal Hitze erzeugt wird durch die Verbrennung eines Brennstoffs und dann ein Generator angetrieben wird, der letztendlich den Strom erzeugt. Also da geht es über Wärmeenergie bei hohen Temperaturen, mechanische Energie und letztendlich aus der mechanischen Energie wird dann elektrische Energie produziert. Und bei der Photovoltaik, da scheint die Sonne drauf und hinten kommt Strom raus. Das ist also praktisch der Clou dieser Technologie und wird deswegen eben auch in Raumschiffen verwendet. Da dreht sich nichts, da bewegt sich nichts, kann auch nur ganz wenig kaputt gehen. Und es bringt auch kein Raumschiff zum Trudeln, weil da irgendwas rotiert. Also das ist so der Vorteil. Und natürlich bei irrtischen Anwendungen ist der Vorteil, da ist keine Mechanik, da ist kein Druck, keine Temperatur. Das Ding steht da ruhig in der Landschaft und produziert Strom. Und das ist natürlich etwas sehr Angenehmes. Gegenteil sind eben diese solarthermischen Dampfkraftwerke. Da konzentriert man Sonnenenergie auf hunderte Grad Celsius, macht damit Dampf bei hohem Druck. Also reden wir auch schon wieder von 100 Bar Druck. Und diese Spiegel, die die Sonnen, die das Sonnenlicht konzentrieren, müssen nachgeführt werden. Also die Folgen der Sonne, sodass da auch eine Mechanik ist, die auch wieder störenfällig ist letztendlich. Oder nicht störenfällig, aber aufwendig ist. Und dann haben wir da hinten noch ein Dampfkraftwerk, also wie ein Kohlekraftwerk, das aber dann mit der Hochtemperatur Sonnenenergie betrieben wird. Das hat erst mal, oder sagen wir mal, dieses Dampfkraftwerk produziert, dann auch erst mal nur Strom, wenn die Sonne scheint. Aber diese Wärme bei der hohen Temperatur, die kann man jetzt sehr elegant wegspeichern erst mal. Also wenn man gerade keinen Strombedarf hat, nimmt man die 400°C und heizt damit einen Tank auf, der mit einer Flüssigkeit gefüllt wird, die bei 400°C eben noch gutartig ist, sage ich mal. Das ist jetzt in dem Fall in Spanien geschmolzenes Salz, also Nitratsalz, was da aufgeschmolzen wird.
Geschmolzenes Salz?
Geschmolzenes Salz in einem großen Topf sozusagen.
Wie heiß muss denn das werden?
Also das zirkuliert zwischen 300 und 400°C. 400°C ist es heiß. Und um die Energie abzugeben dann wieder später für die Dampfverzeugung, wird es von 400 auf 300°C abgekühlt. Und am nächsten Tag, wenn die Sonne wieder scheint, wird es wieder von 300 auf 400°C aufgereizt. Sodass ein solches Kraftwerk dann Tag und Nacht Strom erzeugen kann über die Dampfturbine. Das ist der Vorteil dieser Technologie. Sie müssen also nicht Strom speichern wie bei der Photovoltaik. Da müssen Sie direkt die Elektronen nehmen, die aus der Zelle kommen, weil da kommen direkt Elektronen raus und nichts zwischendurch. Und die können Sie in einer Batterie speichern oder im großen Maßstab jetzt ein Pumpspeicherkraftwerk zum Beispiel bauen und Wasser auf den Berg hochpumpen. Und nachts, wenn Sie Strom brauchen, lassen Sie das Wasser ab und über eine Wasserturbine können Sie dann nachts auch Strom erzeugen. Also da müssen Sie Strom speichern letztendlich. Das ist wiederum der Nachteil dieser Technologie. Bei den solarthermischen Kraftwerken können Sie Wärme speichern und das ist relativ gutartig.
Trotzdem sind die, wenn ich jetzt die Zahlen noch richtig erinnere, ist Solarthermie jetzt noch nicht im Ansatz so weit ausgebaut wie Photovoltaik, was jetzt die Kapazitäten betrifft.
Genau, also 2 Gigawatt zu 70 Gigawatt. Warum ist das so? Die Photovoltaik haben Sie vielleicht sogar in Ihrer Uhr. Die ist also in ganz allerkleinsten Maßstab. Ja, hat jeder praktisch irgendwo stehen im Taschenrechner in der Uhr. Ist im kleinsten Maßstab anwendbar. Man kann sich 1 Kilowatt aufs Dach schnallen oder auch 10 Kilowatt. Das kann jeder Häuslebauer wuppen, dieses Projekt. Deswegen gibt es da einen Markt. Wir haben natürlich auch Förderinstrumente, wie das deutsche Einspeisegesetz zum Beispiel, die dann einen entsprechenden Tarif ermöglichen, sodass man wirtschaftlich so ein Projekt realisieren kann. Tatsächlich auch schon größere Projekte inzwischen. Bei der Solarthermie, da ist die kleinste Einheit, die man sich so vorstellen kann, 5 Megawatt, also 5000 Kilowatt. Und eigentlich eine vernünftige Einheit sind dann 50.000 Kilowatt.
Was heißt die kleinste, die man sich vorstellen kann?
Die man überhaupt sinnvoll irgendwie bauen kann.
Sinnvoll im Sinne von wirtschaftlich?
Ja, und wo es noch Dampfturbinen gibt dafür in der Größenordnung, die irgendwie halbwegs noch einen Wirkungsgrad haben, der vertretbar ist. Und 50.000, also 50 Megawatt, ist so das, was man normalerweise machen möchte, damit man eben eine wirtschaftliche, attraktive Situation erreicht. Und das heißt natürlich, man muss von vornherein sehr viel mehr Geld in die Hand nehmen, um so ein Projekt zu stemmen. Wenn man dann auch noch ein Speicher dazu baut und ein weiteres Solarfeld, um diesen Speicher tagsüber zu füllen und eben nachts auch Strom zu haben, dann verdoppelt sich schon wieder diese Investition für das Solarfeld. Und dann kommen sie zum Beispiel beim solarthermischen Kraftwerk, was jetzt theoretisch letztendlich Grundlast liefern kann. Also 7.000 Stunden im Jahr voller Leistung Strom liefern kann. So was geht mit so einem solarthermischen Kraftwerk in Ägypten unter guten meteorologischen Bedingungen. Da hätten sie eine Investition von über 10.000 Euro pro Kilowatt, während eben ein Kohlekraftwerk 1.500 Euro pro Kilowatt kostet, installierte Leistung also fast ein Zehntel nur. Dann aber natürlich 40 Jahre lang Kohle verbrennt. Die haben sie im anderen Fall dann nicht mehr.
Mit den entsprechenden Langzeitfolgen, die das alles hat.
Und diese große Investition sowohl relativ als auch absolut, wir reden dann von wirklich hunderten Millionen Euro für ein solches Kraftwerk, die kann einfach nicht jeder stemmen. Und das hat natürlich bisher den Vorteil ausgemacht zwischen Photovoltaik, Windenergie und diesen solarthermischen Kraftwerken.
Also kurz gesagt, Photovoltaik ist eigentlich schon eine ganz gut beherrschte Technologie, die lässt sich leicht anbringen. Aber der große Pferdefuß ist einfach, es ist eigentlich nur so für die unmittelbare Stromversorgung wirklich ideal geeignet. Und in dem Moment, wo man speichern muss, wird es knifflig. Aber es ist ja auch möglich.
Ja, es ist möglich.
Bei Häusern wird es ja dann auch in Wärme umgesetzt. Aber die Verluste sind dann relativ hoch, oder wie?
Naja, in Wärme wird man primär jetzt, also den Elektroboiler wird man da primär nicht betreiben wollen. Das ist dann noch ein bisschen teuer. Aber letztendlich schon, ja, also sie machen halt irgendwas damit. Sie betreiben Geräte und ja, das ist so lange in Ordnung, wie sie eine Backup-Technologie haben, die sozusagen die Lücke füllt, wenn die Sonne nicht scheint. Dann ist das super, ne? Also sie sparen ja immer Brennstoff oder auch Energie, wenn die Sonne scheint. Dann kommt der Strom eben aus der Solarzelle. Wunderbar, auch beim Wind. Wenn der Wind weht, sparen sie bei allen anderen Kraftwerken Brennstoff, weil die können runtergefahren werden. Wenn der Wind dann weg ist, müssen sie die anderen Kraftwerke wieder hochfahren. Also solange sie diese Backup-Technologie haben, ist das wunderbar. Und dann brauchen sie natürlich, um die Lücken zu füllen, auch Brennstoff wieder. Wenn sie jetzt diese Lücken auch noch loswerden wollen, im Sinne von erneuerbar bereitstellen wollen, dann brauchen sie erneuerbare Technologien, die flexibel Strom liefern können. Also die nach Bedarf Elektrizität erzeugen können, mit der gewünschten Leistung und über den gewünschten Zeitraum. Das heißt, sie brauchen erneuerbare Energieträger. Und da haben wir die Wasserkraft bei großen Speicherwasserkraftwerken. Da haben wir die Biomasse, die ist speicherbar. Wir haben vielleicht mal in größerem Maßstab auch die Geothermie. Die Erdwärme ist ja schon sehr gut gespeicherte Energie. Und wir haben diese solarthermischen Kraftwerke, die eben auch die Wärme speichern und dann nach Bedarf Strom liefern können. Das sind so die Technologien, die Regelenergie und flexible Leistung liefern können. Wind und Photovoltaik liefern eben nicht flexible Leistung, sondern die liefern Leistung, wenn die Sonne scheint. Da ist man so abhängig von der Ressource. Beide in Kombination letztendlich können den Strombedarf decken. Wir haben dann einfach variable Erneuerbare, die als Brennstoff-Spargerät funktionieren, und flexible Erneuerbare, die letztendlich die Lücken füllen. Und genauso sind letztendlich auch unsere Szenarien ausgelegt, um in eine nachhaltige Energiezukunft zu kommen. Diese beiden Formen erneuerbarer Energie brauchen wir. Wir sträuben uns dann immer gegen die Meinung, dass man es nur mit einer dieser Technologien oder nur mit wenigen dieser Technologien schaffen kann. Also manche meinen, das kann man alles mit der Photovoltaik machen oder alles mit dem Wind. Und das ist eben nicht so. Sondern man braucht eben diese Kombination aller erneuerbaren Quellen, die variablen und die flexiblen. Und aus beiden kann man letztendlich den Strom nach Bedarf zur Verfügung stellen.
Eine Frage, die natürlich an der Stelle schnell aufkommt, ist, wenn alles irgendwie jederzeit on demand irgendeine Lücke füllen soll, brauchen wir ja auch die entsprechenden Netze, die die Energie dann auch an den richtigen Ort bringen. Und derzeit haben wir ja noch eher so eine Netzwerkinfrastruktur, die eben von diesen großen Installationen, nicht nur, aber auch von Atomkraftwerken zum Beispiel und großen Kohlekraftwerken eben ausgeht, die dann eben mehr oder weniger liefern, je nachdem, wie die Nachfrage ist. Aber wenn das jetzt eben aus so vielen, sehr viel dezentraler angelegten Kleinst- und Mittelkraftwerken kommen soll, müssen ja auch diese Netze entsprechend ausgelegt sein. Das sind sie aber heutzutage nicht unbedingt, oder?
Ja, ne, die kriegen lokal schon ab und zu Probleme, wenn zu viel von den Dächern sozusagen kommt an Energie, von den Photovoltaikanlagen. Da gibt es lokal dann schon Probleme, um diese Energie dann wieder auf eine höhere Ebene zu bringen und zu verteilen, großräumig. Vor allem ist es ja meistens so, die Nachbarn haben ja dasselbe Problem, weil dort auch gerade die Sonne scheint. Da muss man das schon sehr weiträumig verteilen.
Warum braucht ihr nicht ein bisschen Strom?
Das ist aber natürlich in dem Maße, wie wir Energie verbrauchen, gar kein so großes Problem. Theoretisch könnte man ja den Strom, der vom Dach kommt, von der Photovoltaikanlage direkt verbrauchen oder auch zu Hause in der Batterie speichern. Dann taucht dieses Problem im Netz erst gar nicht auf. Das kann man machen. Das wird man auch, denke ich, bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt machen. Dann bleiben immer noch ein paar Lücken übrig. Diese Lücken erfordern dann flexible Geräte, die diese Lücken dann letztendlich noch nach Bedarf füllen. Das ist der Punkt. Man verfolgt alle Ansätze. Speicherung, Lastmanagement auch. Man kann sich ja auch ein bisschen an die Sonne anpassen mit seiner Waschmaschine. Es ist durchaus möglich, dass man seinen Stromverbrauch etwas an das Angebot anpasst. Vor allem, wenn das so gesteuert werden kann, dass es noch einen wirtschaftlichen Ertrag liefert. So etwas ist durchaus attraktiv und denkbar.
Waschen nur bei gutem Wetter.
Waschen nur bei gutem Wetter, genau so in der Art. Das hat alles Grenzen, sieht man daraus.
Klar, dann ist die Wäsche natürlich auch nicht so schmutzig.
Dann gibt es noch Möglichkeiten, Elektroautos, die ja aufkommen könnten, in nächster Zeit auch wieder als Puffer und Speicher für solche Schwankungen auf lokaler Ebene zu verwenden. Also wenn Überschussenergie dann zum Beispiel ins Auto gehen kann, dann muss man auch wieder nicht das Netz belasten. Und da gibt es sehr viele mannigfaltige Möglichkeiten, um die Probleme, die da entstehen durch Erneuerbare, die in der Regel variabel sind, doch zu dämpfen. Und letztendlich auch natürlich den Ausbau der Netze. Also das steht natürlich an, wenn man jetzt sehr viel Offshore-Windenergie zum Beispiel aus Norddeutschland nach Süddeutschland holen will. Da muss man schon was machen, um das Netz auszubauen. Da gibt es aber auf dieser oberen Ebene des Netzausbaus, da gibt es dann auch mehrere Möglichkeiten. Einmal das Wechselstromnetz, wie wir es jetzt haben, verstärken. Also dass die Durchlässigkeit dieses Netzes größer wird, da muss man einfach Leitungen dazu bauen. Oder man geht auf die Hochspannungs-Gleichstrom-Übertragung. Das ist so ein Vorschlag, der zum Beispiel von der DESERTEC-Initiative propagiert wurde, dass man so eine Art Stromautobahn schafft, die auf allerhöchster Spannungsebene über das Wechselstrom hinweg, über große Entfernungen Elektrizität transportieren kann, mit nur geringen Verlusten. Und diese Elektrizität wird dann in Ballungszentren praktisch in das Wechselstromnetz, in das vorhandene eingespeist. Man gab ganz flapsig, wenn irgendwo ein Kernkraftwerk abgeschaltet wird, dann ist ja dort in der Regel ein Wechselstromnetz, was eine gewisse Leistung vertragen kann. Und genau hier kann man dann so einen Punkt legen, um so eine HGÜ, Hochspannungs-Gleichstrom-Übertragungsleitung einspeisen zu lassen. Und von dort aus kann man dann wieder über Wechselstrom den Strom an die Verbraucher verteilen. Die Infrastruktur zur Verteilung ist ja da, das ist das Wechselstromnetz. Die Infrastruktur für den Fernentransport von Elektrizität, die fehlt noch. Das kann das Wechselstrom nicht sehr gut. Das würde da, also über die Entfernungen wird ja im Rahmen von der Wüstenstrominitiative da propagiert, dass man von Marokko zum Beispiel bis Deutschland Strom überträgt. Das wären 2500 Kilometer. Das würde über das Wechselstromnetz letztendlich gar nicht gehen, sondern sehr hohe Verluste auch erzeugen.
Da würde ich ganz gerne noch mal so ein bisschen generell nachfragen, weil das ist ja eigentlich so, man hat sich ja so ein bisschen an diesen Gedanken gewöhnt, große Energiemengen werden über Wechselstromnetze übertragen. Und das ist so die Technologie, die sich eigentlich über die Jahre weit über 100 Jahre hinweg durchgesetzt hat, weil sie Vorteile bietet eben dafür. Während es ja am Anfang, als so Strom noch erfunden wurde und Tesla da auch seine Auseinandersetzung hatte mit Edison, der ja wiederum Gleichstrom propagierte, hat sich dann letzten Endes Wechselstrom durchgesetzt. Warum hat sich das damals jetzt durchgesetzt? Und was ist jetzt auf einmal anders, dass man jetzt auf einmal doch wieder über Gleichstrom nachdenkt? Wie muss man das einsatzieren?
Die Wechselstromtechnologie ist perfekt, um Strom zu verteilen. An viele kleine Verbraucher, die auf niedrigem Spannungsniveau arbeiten, also 220 Volt aus der Steckdose, aber vielleicht 400 Kilovolt oben im Hochspannungsnetz. Wechselstrom kann man sehr schön runter transformieren von einem Spannungsniveau aufs andere. Das ist für ein Verteilsystem perfekt. Für die Übertragung über große Entfernungen ist es nicht perfekt, aber das war jetzt anfangs nicht so das Problem, weil ja überall Kraftwerke dann stehen. Man baut halt die Kraftwerke in die Nähe der Verbrauchszentren und dann braucht man gar nicht über große Entfernungen Energie transportieren.
Was ist eine große Entfernung?
Naja, hunderte, hunderte, 500 Kilometer, sage ich mal. Wenn man jetzt so weit gehen müsste, dann würde man nicht unbedingt außen stand jetzt einen Wechselstrom.
Findet aber jetzt in Deutschland so selten statt?
Findet gar nicht statt, weil ja in 20 Kilometer Entfernung ist schon das nächste Kraftwerk, was letztendlich meinen Strom liefert und dann 20 Kilometer weiter wieder eins. Und die sind über dieses Wechselstromnetz verbunden, sodass der Ferntransport in dieser Form jetzt nur ausnahmsweise mal stattfindet, wenn irgendwo Überschüsse auftreten. Das wird dann aber sozusagen weitergereicht von einem Kraftwerk zum anderen, verstehen Sie?
Ja, also der Strom, den ich aus Frankreich beziehe, beziehe ich nicht wirklich.
Der kommt hier aus der Gegend.
Die holen sich das wieder beim Nachbarn, der holt sich das beim Nachbarn, das gleicht sich so aus wie Wasser.
Und genau, so ist es. Und bei einer wirklichen Stromfernübertragung, also wenn jetzt sozusagen wirklich dauerhaft Strom aus einer Richtung in die andere Richtung fließt, zum Beispiel aus Marokko nach Deutschland und dort eingespeist werden soll, da macht das dann doch wenig Sinn. Also das geht bis zu einem bestimmten Maß, auch was ist auch begrenzt, doch die Durchlässigkeit des Netzes zum Beispiel, auch die Transferkapazität zwischen den Ländern ist ja begrenzt. Und die wird in der Regel auch genutzt, um Ausgleichseffekte zu schaffen, also Ausgleichsmöglichkeiten zu schaffen. Sie ist nicht so sehr dafür da, um jetzt konstant Strom in eine Richtung zu liefern. Und da bestehen gewisse Grenzen. Und da ist eben die Idee, dass man solche Hochspannungs-Gleichstrom-Übertragungsleitungen baut. Die arbeiten praktisch mit Gleichstrom, nicht mit Wechselstrom, sondern mit Gleichstrom wie aus einer Batterie. Zwei Pole, plus minus, sehr hohe Spannung, bis zu 800.000 Volt haben die inzwischen. Und die übertragen dann sehr verlustarm, also 2000 Kilometer, 7 Prozent Verlust, Energie von A nach B. Das wird in China gerade gebaut. Da werden die Wasserkraftwerke 2000 Kilometer von Shanghai entfernt, zum Beispiel mit Shanghai verbunden, über eine HGÜ-Leitung. Die liefern dann Strom nach Bedarf in das Ballungszentrum.
Jetzt so sieben Schluchten damm da um Yangtzeh.
Das ist im Prinzip genau das Konzept.
Drei Schluchten damm ist es, oder sind es sieben Schluchten?
Das sind drei, ja. Das ist genau das Konzept. Erneuerbare Energie da zu ernten, wo sie gut verfügbar ist und ergiebig, und in ein Ballungszentrum zu schicken. Und das machen die genau über eine HGÜ-Leitung.
Ist das jetzt ohne technische Herausforderungen, so eine Gleichstromleitung?
Stand der Technik. Das ist europäische Technologie von Siemens und ABB gebaut letztendlich in China.
Was muss da jetzt mehr gemacht werden, außer dass man so ein Kabel irgendwie in der Luft hängt? Also ist das in der Luft, ist das im Boden?
Die in China sind in der Luft, das sind Freileitungen auch. Man kann sie aber auch durchs Wasser legen, das ist einer der Vorteile der HGÜ. Also man kann hunderte Kilometer durchs Wasser gehen, das kann man mit Wechselstrom gar nicht. Da kommt nach 100 Kilometern nichts mehr raus, das ist immer flapsig. Und man kann sie auch ganz gut eingraben, sodass sie auch für unterirdische Trassen brauchbar sind. Das nennt sich dann HGÜ-Light-Technologie.
Und bei solchen hohen Voltzahlen gibt es keine Probleme mit Übersprungshandlungen, Insolierung, Thermik?
Das ist alles Stand der Technik.
Also es gab bisher eigentlich nur keinen Anlass, es zu tun. Und jetzt, wo sich das gesamte Energiemodell dahingehend verschiebt, dass man sagt, wir müssen eigentlich weg von dieser zentralen Versorgung, weil nicht überall da, wo der Strom verbraucht wird, kann man ihn effizient produzieren. Das ging nur so lange, wie wir da in einer glücklichen Situation sind, weil da gerade eine Talsperre in der Nähe ist, wo Wasserkraft ist, oder es sich jetzt um einen Ort handelt, der besonders viel Sonnenenergie gewinnen kann, aber vielleicht auch nicht so hohe Verbräuche hat, bzw. die anderen schon angesprochenen Sachen, Biomassekraftwerke etc. oder eben andere Abfallprodukte von anderen Kraftwerken. Und jetzt sagt man, okay, Sonne ist eigentlich das einzige Nennenswerte, was irgendwie immer da ist. Weil wenn das nicht da ist, gibt es die Erde ohnehin nicht mehr. Dann muss man sich darüber auch gar keine Gedanken mehr machen. Und dann gehen wir doch einfach mal dahin, wo es wirklich richtig heiß ist, damit das auch effizient ist. Und da geht man dann nach Spanien und dann geht man dann auch nach Afrika.
Ja, man erreicht einfach eine gewisse Qualität der Energie. In Ägypten ist es halt möglich, mit solchen thermischen Wärmespeichern ein Dampfkraftwerk zu bauen, was solarbetrieben ist, was bis zu 7500 Vollerstunden im Jahr hat. Das Jahr hat ja nur 8760 Stunden. Das heißt, man kann praktisch dauerhaft ständig Leistungen nach Bedarf liefern. Man kann die auch anders bauen, sodass sie eben wirklich Regel-Energie liefern und Lücken füllen, die irgendwie entstehen. Das kann man auch. Aber man kann eben auch Kraftwerke bauen, die dauerhaft, konstant kontinuierlich laufen. Und diese Qualität kriegt man eben nur da im Süden hin. Erstens ist das Wetter besser. Da scheint fast jeden Tag die Sonne. Zweitens ist der Breitengrad niedriger, sodass auch die Winkel zwischen Sonnenenergie und Kollektoren günstiger sind, sodass wir da weniger optische Verluste haben.
Also man muss die Kollektoren nicht so schräg stellen.
Genau, kann man zum Teil gar nicht. Also bei so einem Rinnen-Kollektor, der liegt ja nun mal horizontal am Boden, den kann man jetzt nicht nennenswert nach oben kippen, damit er im Winter jetzt ein bisschen besser zur Sonne steht. Das geht nicht. Man führt ihm zwar der Sonne nach, von morgens bis abends. So eine Parabolrinne ist 150 Meter lang.
Das ist einfach eine mechanische Unmöglichkeit. Also das ist schon möglich, aber aufwendig.
Es gibt selten die Bedingungen am Boden, dass man das so bauen könnte, sondern man legt die flach hin natürlich. Und je weiter man zum Äquator geht, desto geringer ist der Winkel, desto höher steht die Sonne im Jahr im Durchschnitt und desto geringer sind dann die optischen Verluste dieser Kollektoren. Und daraus ergibt sich eine sehr hohe Qualität der Versorgung, diese Konstanz der Versorgung. Selbst in Spanien haben wir im Winter einen Einbruch des Ertrags auf bis zu 20 Prozent runter gegenüber Sommer. Also 80 Prozent weniger in den Wintermonaten als in den Sommermonaten. Während in Ägypten zum Beispiel, am Aswan, da hätte man vielleicht mal 20, 30 Prozent weniger im Winter. Und diese Konstanz, das ist eine Qualität.
Man könnte ja auch noch weiter nach Süden gehen.
Ja, aber wenn man dann über die Sahara hinausgeht, wird es wieder trüb, feucht, tropisch. Und da hat man dann weniger die Sonnenenergie als Wasserkraft.
Aber da hört man noch mehr Sand. Ist das nicht ein Problem?
In der Sahara den Sand? Aber es sind gerade mal 20 Prozent der Saharas Sandflächen und der Rest sind eher Steinwüsten. Und natürlich sucht man sich nicht gerade die Wanderdüne aus, um so ein Nachkraftwerk zu errichten. Obwohl bei allen Artikeln über DESERTEC witzigerweise eine Wanderdüne dann zu sehen ist, das ist natürlich ein Ausschlusskriterium und kein geeigneter Standort.
Vielleicht müssen wir an der Stelle den Begriff DESERTEC auch mal nach vorne holen. Das ist ja auch so ein Thema, was jetzt schon seit längerer Zeit durch Medien und gesellschaftliche Diskussionen geht. Was verbirgt sich hinter diesem Begriff und was hat das jetzt hier auch vor allem mit diesem Institut hier zu tun?
Ja, ich kann mal ein bisschen auf die Geschichte zurückgehen. Im Jahr 2003 hat der Club of Rome und der Hamburger Klimaschutzfonds die Trans-Mediterranean Renewable Energy Cooperation gegründet. Das war ein Netzwerk aus Wissenschaftlern, Ingenieuren, Hochschullehrern, Politiker waren da teilweise auch dabei. Die haben ein Bild gemalt und haben gesagt, wir müssen erneuerbare Energie dort ernten, wo sie sehr gut verfügbar ist und von da in die Ballungszentren bringen. Also Wasserkraft zum Beispiel auch in regnerischen Bergen ernten, Biomasse in den Wäldern in Skandinavien und Mitteleuropa, Sonnenenergie in der Sahara und Windenergie an den windigen Küsten.
Was qualifiziert diesen Club of Rome, an der Stelle solche Schlüsse zu ziehen?
Der Club of Rome hat ja immer gesagt, wir haben Grenzen des Wachstums. Jetzt wollte er hier mal auch eine Lösung anbieten, wie man diese Grenzen praktisch überwinden kann oder zumindest zu tragbaren Lösungen in der Zukunft kommen kann, indem man den Footprint, den die Menschheit verursacht, letztendlich verträglich gestaltet. Und das ist so ein Element dieser Strategie. Und das hat auch eine gewisse zwingende Logik, weil da, wo sehr viel Energie in der Umwelt ist, also an aufregnerischen Bergen, windigen Küsten, heißen Wüsten, da wohnen tatsächlich wenig Menschen, weil da ist es ungemütlich. Das ergibt sich aus der Natur der Sache. Und da, wo die Menschen sind, Ballungsgebiete, da ist eigentlich recht wenig erneuerbare Energie, da ist es gemütlicher sozusagen in der Umwelt. Also ganz witziger Zusammenhang, woraus sich eine gewisse zwingende Logik gibt dieser Idee. Also die Energie woanders zu ernten, als man sie braucht. Und da haben die dieses Bild gemalt. Wir erschließen diese Standorte durch Vernetzung über HGÜ-Leitungen mit den Balance-Zentren. Und dann wurden wir im Jahr 2004 beauftragt vom Bundesumweltministerium, dieses Konzept zu prüfen. Und da haben wir drei Studien gemacht, MED-CSP, Trans-CSP und AQUA-CSP, in denen wir 50 Länder in der Region Europa, Nordafrika, Mittlerer Osten, inklusive arabischer Halbinsel, untersucht haben einzeln und geschaut haben, welche erneuerbaren Energiepotenziale sind verfügbar? Windenergie, Sonnenergie, Biomasse, Wasserkraft usw. In jedem einzelnen Land. Welches Portfolio an Technologien haben wir heute? Und wie können wir jetzt die Stromversorgung dieser Länder Richtung Nachhaltigkeit sozusagen umgestalten?
Auf welche Länder bezog sich das jetzt?
Das sind 50 Länder von Skandinavien bis Marokko bis Oman.
Und das verteilte sich dann auf drei separate Studien?
Nee, die wurden alle in den drei Studien betrachtet mit unterschiedlichen Schwerpunkten der Fragestellung.
Ach so, also unterschiedliche Aspekte, aber immer diese 50 Länder. Wie kann man jetzt auf diese 50? Also das im Wesentlichen Europa und Nordafrika.
Möller Osten, Nordafrika, genau.
Ah, ok, alles, was uns hier unmittelbar umgibt sozusagen.
Ums Mittelmeer herum sozusagen.
Das heißt, man hat im Prinzip so eine komplette Landkarte der Nutzbarkeit dieser Orte für bestimmte Energiegewinnungskonzepte gewonnen.
Ja, genau. Also es gab damals schon sehr viele Energieversorgungsszenarien für Zukunft, Zukunftsszenarien für die Versorgung. Nur die waren eins für Afrika, eins für Europa, eins für Nordamerika, Südamerika, das waren so getrennt. Und wir haben jetzt mal ganz bewusst diese Grenze zwischen Afrika und Europa entfernt. Das war schon mal was Neues an dieser Übung. Und wir haben dann auch eben die solarthermischen Kraftwerke als Option mit reingenommen, die bisher auch in anderen Szenarien einfach nicht vorkamen. Aus mir auch nicht ganz verständlichen Gründen, aber das war bisher so dann gewesen. Deswegen heißen die auch CSP-Studien, also Concentrating Solar Power. Das war das neue technische Element, was wir damit berücksichtigt haben.
Also Solarthermie stand an der Stelle schon im Mittelpunkt der Studie, im Titel auch. Einfach aus dieser generellen Erkenntnis raus, wir müssen woanders produzieren, als wir es verbrauchen. Und das bedingt diese Technologie auch, wenn es nicht unbedingt das einzige ist, was dann geprüft wurde, oder?
Nee, das war natürlich nur ein Element des Ganzen. Wir haben alle Potenziale für Erneuerbare untersucht, wir haben auch alle Technologien eingebaut. Und wir haben dann für jedes Land ein einzelnes Szenario gemacht, was im Jahr 2000 startet. Und den Übergang bis zum Jahr 2050 zeigt, der Stromversorgung.
Also wie sich der Energiebedarf des jeweiligen Landes vermutlich entwickeln wird?
Wie sich der Bedarf vermutlich entwickeln wird und wie man ihn verträglich decken kann. Und zwar eben umweltverträglich in erster Linie. Klimaschutz haben wir da berücksichtigt, die Klimaschutzziele, auch sonstige Umwelteffekte, wie Landverbrauch zum Beispiel, Floster ein. Letztendlich auch die Versorgungssicherheit, also bei Strom ist es ja wichtig, dass der Strom nach Bedarf geliefert wird. Und auch ökonomische Verträglichkeit. Das war eine ganz spannende Diskussion, weil anfangs sind wir auf das Ziel hinausgegangen, das muss konkurrenzfähig sein. Erneuerbare Energien, die reinkommen, müssen konkurrenzfähig sein. Da haben wir schnell festgestellt, als Zielfunktion macht das gar keinen Sinn, weil die dauernd teurer werden, also jedes Jahr teurer werden. Das heißt, eine Zielfunktion zu setzen, ich möchte konkurrenzfähig sein, mit etwas, was jedes Jahr teurer wird, ist in sich sinnlos. Da haben wir schnell festgestellt, wir müssen eine andere Zielfunktion im ökonomischen Bereich setzen. Da sind wir auf die Energiekosten des Jahres 2000 gekommen. Wir haben gesagt, die zukünftige Energieversorgung soll wieder so teuer sein, wie im Jahr 2000 als Zielfunktion. Das hat sehr gut funktioniert, dann gaben sich sehr klare Ergebnisse daraus. Manche Technologien sind eindeutig rausgeflogen, manche sind eindeutig reingekommen mit dieser Zielsetzung. Vor allem die Erneuerbaren sind damit reingekommen. Anders ist das auch nicht erreichbar. Das Ziel wurde zwar nicht erreicht, aber es ging in die Richtung zumindest. Die Kosten wurden zunächst stabilisiert, mittelfristig, und dann konnten sie in manchen Fällen, wo günstige Erneuerbare Energiepotenziale vorhand waren, sogar wieder reduziert werden gegenüber heute. Aber die Kosten des Jahres 2000 zu erreichen, ist nicht überall erreichbar. Das ist als Zielfunktion gut, aber nicht unbedingt erreichbar.
Die Daten gleich von 50 Ländern zu erheben, erscheint mir ein recht komplexer Vorgang zu sein. Kommt man denn so problemlos an diese ganzen Rahmendaten ran?
Ja, also damals, 2004, 2005, war es schon so, dass man sehr gut im Internet recherchieren konnte. Wir hatten Partner aus vielen Ländern, auch aus Nordafrika, dabei in der Studie. Also New Energy Algeria zum Beispiel, die ENREA in Ägypten, also auch die Energiebehörde dort, die uns dann mit den Daten versorgt haben, die wir nicht so einfach aus dem Internet ziehen konnten. In Europa war es kein Problem, das ist alles gut dokumentiert und da kann man auch gut Szenarien des Bedarfs machen. Also das war schon anspruchsvoll, aber jetzt nicht unmöglich. Und letztendlich ist es auch ganz gut gelungen. Was wir nicht machen wollten, ist eine Prognose. Das betone ich dabei immer. Also Szenarien in unserem Verständnis sind keine Prognosen, was passieren wird, sondern wir haben ein Ziel gesetzt, eine Zielfunktion. Diese Zielfunktion war Nachhaltigkeit, das heißt kostengünstige Versorgung, sichere Versorgung und umweltkompatible Versorgung. Dieses Ziel haben wir gesetzt und dann geschaut, wie kommen wir von heute, im Startpunkt Jahr 2000, zu diesem Ziel, sagen wir mal im Jahr 2050. Diesen Übergang, das war eigentlich das Wichtige. Die Zahlen, wie sich dieser Mix aus verschiedenen Energiequellen zusammensetzt, der ist gar nicht so wichtig, sondern die strategischen Überlegungen, die sich daraus ergeben haben, die vielen Paradigmenwechsel, die wir da sehen konnten bei dieser Übung, das war eigentlich das Spannende daran. Und die Studien stehen heute noch im Internet, sind runterladbar, kann sich jeder anschauen, werden auch noch kontrovers diskutiert. Aber letztendlich stehen diese strategischen Erkenntnisse immer noch und bewahrheiten sich zunehmend jetzt im Laufe der Zeit. Das ist das Schöne. Die Zahlen, das Zahlenwerk selbst, also wie viel Windenergie jetzt seit dem Jahr 2000 installiert wurde, müssten wir heute aus heutiger Sicht nach oben hin korrigieren. Das hat teilweise schneller stattgefunden, als wir aus Sicht des Jahres 2005 noch dachten. Und das Witzigste sind halt die Energiepreise. Da haben wir im Jahr 2005 ein Szenario der Internationalen Energieagentur verwendet, den World Energy Outlook. Und die Brennstoffpreise, die da noch angenommen wurden, das dürfte jetzt um Faktor 3 oder 4 höher sein. Heute schon, als die im Jahr 2050 vorausgesehen haben. Also da hat sich wirklich eine ganz dramatische Entwicklung, ganz anders entwickelt, als wir aus der Sicht haben.
Aber die eigentlichen Ergebnisse auch weiter unterstreicht.
Aber die das letztendlich nur verstärken. Und auch die Dringlichkeit, da aktiv zu werden in der Richtung, zeigen.
Was war denn jetzt aber so konkret dieses Ergebnis? Ich meine, wenn man sich 50 Länder anschaut, bis hin zu Skandinavien, da wird sich das Bild ja dann sehr unterschiedlich darstellen. Was wir ja schon ein paar Mal testiert haben, ist ja auch nachvollziehbar. Also da, wo es heiß ist und so weiter, da baut man halt die Solarthermie. Aber was ist denn zum Beispiel für die anderen Länder abgefallen? Also es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass man aus Norwegen keine erneuerbaren Energien kennen würde. Da wird Wasserkraft zum Einsatz gebracht, etc. Das hat ja auch alles seine Potenziale.
Genau, also jedes Land hat einen ganz eigenen Energiemix, der so zusammengesetzt ist, dass erstrangig erstmal die heimischen Energiequellen ausgeschöpft werden, soweit das geht, umweltverträglich ist und mit der Versorgungssicherheit übereinstimmt. Und erst dann wird letztendlich Energie importiert. Das kann zunächst auch erneuerbare Energie aus Nachbarländern sein. Und an dritter Stelle wird dann eben weiterhin fossile Energie da verwendet, wo Lücken zu füllen sind, die eben selbst mit den speicherbaren Erneuerbaren schwer zu füllen sind. Entweder gibt es nicht genug Potenzial oder es gibt nicht genug flexibles Potenzial an erneuerbarer Energie, was in der Lage wäre, die Lücken zu füllen. Und so ist das Szenario letztendlich aufgebaut, also in so ein bisschen Prioritäten. Erstmal erneuerbare heimisch, dann erneuerbare von auswärts und dann letztendlich am Schluss fossile, um die letzte Lücke zu stopfen. Das führte aber dazu, dass diese letzte Lücke so klein wurde, da reden wir dann von 20 Prozent noch im Jahr 2050, dass sie letztendlich mit den Klimaschutzzielen in Einklang ist. Also die 20 Prozent im Jahr 2050 wäre schon etwas, was mit dem 2-Grad-Ziel jetzt vereinbar wäre. Und da ist ja nicht Ende der Fahnenstange 2050, sondern der Gradient der Entwicklung zeigt, es kann noch weiter reduziert werden ab da. Also insofern hat das Szenario gezeigt für alle Länder, dass es einen konsistenten Pfad in so eine nachhaltige Zukunft gibt. Wir haben nichts optimiert oder irgendwie kostengünstig oder was, sondern wir haben einfach gesagt, hier es gibt einen Pfad und der ist mit diesen Nachhaltigkeitszielen letztendlich konform, die wir gesetzt haben. Das ist nicht der billigste, das ist vielleicht auch nicht der beste, auch nicht der schönste oder so, aber es ist einer und der ist konsistent. Das ist der Vorteil dieses Szenarios.
Wenn man jetzt so die Europa-Nordafrika-Karte und Mittlerer Osten so ein bisschen so anmalt, welche erneuerbaren Energien wo jetzt so den Vorrang haben, welches Farbwerk ergibt sich da?
Im Norden Wasserkraft, Windenergie, an den Küsten, Nordsee, Atlantik, Windenergie vor allem. Biomasse ist auch bei uns natürlich gut verfügbar, in den Wäldern, Skandinavien, also Holz als Biomasse. Energiepflanzen haben wir für die Stromerzeugung erstmal ausgeschlossen, also den Anbau von Energiepflanzen, weil das einfach sehr viel Flächen braucht, sehr teuer wird und letztendlich auch nicht so ganz umweltfreundlich ist, wenn man das für die Stromversorgung macht.
Und auch wieder Probleme bei der Nahrungsmittelversorgung.
Genau, also die Konkurrenzsituation. Letztendlich haben wir das ausgeschlossen, sondern letztendlich Biomasse nur Abfallprodukte aus Wäldern, Landwirtschaft und Kommunen verwendet, was aber auch ganz gehörige Mengen sind, also das ist nicht wenig. Dann natürlich, da wo Geothermie verfügbar ist, haben wir die Geothermie-Resourcen ein bisschen verwendet, allerdings sehr vorsichtig, weil man schon wusste, da rappelt es dann manchmal, wenn man bohrt. Also da gibt es noch viel zu tun in der Forschung und in der Entwicklung, aber wir haben diese Technologie auch nicht ausgeschlossen, nur sehr vorsichtig.
Also rappelt im Sinne von Problematik, Erdanbohrung etc.
ist schwierig. Wir sind da schon optimistisch, dass das irgendwann auch mal eine Rolle spielen wird. Und das ist natürlich auch eine sehr gut verfügbare Energieform. Sie ist ja ideal gespeichert in der Erde, sodass sie gewisse Vorteile hat. Aber wie gesagt, das haben wir auch vorsichtig verwendet. Wasserkraft ist bekannt, sehr gut bekannt, aber schon weitgehend ausgeschöpft. Also da kennt man eigentlich die Reserven, die noch da sind. Ja und dann die Sonnenenergie natürlich im Süden. Also Sonnenenergie und Windenergie vor allem in den Ländern Nordafrikas, Mittlerer Osten. Da gibt es da die größten Potenziale. Biomasse, Wasserkraft spielen da eher eine geringere Rolle. Und so ist das aufgeteilt. Das Land, das wirklich alle Quellen nutzen kann, ist Spanien. Das ist ganz toll. Das hat wirklich von allem etwas. Und hat es eigentlich am leichtesten gehabt, um zu so einem nachhaltigen Mix zu kommen. Weil die haben gute Sonnenenergie, gute Windenergie. Die haben Biomasse, die haben Wasserkraft. Sogar ein bisschen Geothermie. Das ist ein Land, das wirklich alles hat und das auch nutzen könnte und auch am schnellsten zu so einer nachhaltigen Versorgung kommen könnte in Europa.
Und auch schon teilweise unterwegs ist. Weil da gibt es ja auch schon solarthermische Installationen.
Ja, da gibt es auch von allen Technologien, gibt es auch schon einen Markt. Weil die Spanier haben Einspeise gesetzt, wie in Deutschland. Das haben sie gerade ausgesetzt wegen der wirtschaftlichen Lage. Was aber natürlich sehr schwierig ist und auch sehr schwer nachzuvollziehen. Weil die erneuerbaren Energien, die sind ein Kostenelement in der Stromversorgung, das konstant ist. Also über die nächsten 20 Jahre, wenn man so einen Einspeisetarif kriegt, werden diese Kosten nicht steigen. Während die Kosten des gesamten Restes der Stromversorgung mit Sicherheit nächstes Jahr höher sein werden als dieses Jahr. Und auf genau dieses Kostenelement zu verzichten und auf den Ausbau dieses Kostenelements, den Ausbau einzustellen, ist mir in der Lage aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar.
Aber ähnliches wird ja auch in Deutschland debattiert.
Ja, das ist genauso wenig verständlich. Wir schaffen hier mit erneuerbaren Energien ein Element unserer Stromversorgung, was nächstes Jahr genauso viel kosten wird wie dieses Jahr. Und übernächstes Jahr auch und in 20 Jahren immer noch. Und das ist ein unglaublich erfolgswirtschaftlicher Wert, den wir da schaffen. Den muss man auch honorieren, wenn es darum geht, ob man jetzt diese Investition tätigt oder nicht. Aber das ist so eine Investition auf jeden Fall wert.
Jetzt nochmal zu dem Begriff DESERTEC. Was verbirgt sich hinter dieser Abkürzung oder diesem Bezeichner? Abkürzung ist ja nur so ein Ansatz.
Naja, Wüstentechnologie letztendlich. Die DESERTEC-Initiativ wurde gegründet, nachdem wir unsere Studien durchgeführt hatten und die Ergebnisse vorgelegt haben. Das abgeschlossen war das im Jahr 2007.
Und auch auf Basis dieser Studien?
Auf der Basis dieser Studien wurde dann diese Initiative, erst die Foundation, gegründet 2009, und dann eben auch die DESERTEC Industrial Initiative. Und letztendlich, ja, kann man so ein bisschen sagen, die Studien haben dazu beigetragen, da das wissenschaftliche Fundament dafür zu legen, zu zeigen, das geht. Und dann haben die eben gesagt, ja, das interessiert uns, da machen wir weiter.
Wer hat das gegründet, also wer ist in dieser Foundation zusammengeschlossen?
Na, das sind ganz verschiedene Leute, die...
Also Personen, Firmen, Staaten...
Ja, in der Foundation, das sind wirklich Personen, die sich für das Thema interessieren und da was machen möchten. Es sind keine Firmen da drin. Also das sind wirklich...
Das ist mehr so ein Sinktank.
Das ist ein Sinktank, genau. Die haben auch zum Beispiel so Initiativen wie das DESERTEC University Network gegründet mit und veranlasst auch, sodass sich einfach die Idee dieses DESERTEC Konzeptes verbreiten soll oder propagieren das. Und das ist eben nicht nur auf die europäische Region bezogen, sondern eben auch auf die ganze Welt. Man kann sowas auch in den USA machen oder in Asien. Letztendlich immer da, wo es eben diese Distanz zwischen Ertragreichen erneuerbaren Energiequellen gibt und den Ballungszentren. Letztendlich kann man das überall da machen. Ein schönes Beispiel ist zum Beispiel Neuseeland. Ich glaube, auf der Südinsel ist da sehr viel Wasserkraft. Und auf der Nordinsel ist die Bevölkerung letztendlich. Und genau zwischen den beiden gibt es so eine Leitung, die den Strom aus der Wasserkraft durchs Meer überträgt zum Ballungszentrum. Also das gibt es auch schon. Das ist jetzt so gesehen noch nicht mal was Neues. Die Neuseeländer machen das seit Jahrzehnten, was hier vorgeschlagen wird.
Auch mit diesen Gleichstromleitungen.
Mit den gleichen Gleichstromleitungen durchs Meer auch. Eben da, wo die Energie ist, ernten und dorthin bringen, wo die Energie gebraucht wird. Also wenn man so will, ein alter Hut.
Klingt eigentlich alles ganz einfach so. Fragt man sich, warum steht das nicht schon längst?
Technisch ist das überall da einfach. Technisch ist es auch einfach, das ist das Stand der Technik. Wird auch weltweit in großem Maßstab gemacht. Also es gibt zum Beispiel eine Verbindung zwischen Norwegen und Holland übers Meer. Es gibt eine zwischen Schweden und Deutschland. Schweden und Polen ist verbunden. Griechenland und Italien sind verbunden. Diese Technologie gibt es überall schon. Die Schwierigkeit ist jetzt, da wo gewünscht wird, einen Ausgleich zwischen zwei Ländern zu machen, wird das auch international gemacht. Um Erneuerbare irgendwo zu ernten und in ein Ballungszentrum zu bringen, da wird es in den Ländern gemacht. Also national, in China, eben Neuseeland, das ist innerhalb der Landesgrenzen. Und die Herausforderung, von dem DESERTEC, von dem Wüstenstrom letztendlich von Marokko nach Deutschland zu bringen, zum Beispiel als Beispiel jetzt, wäre natürlich, diese Energie durch mehrere Länder zu transportieren. Und das ist natürlich eine politische Herausforderung. Da spielen ganz verschiedene Interessen rein, da spielen natürlich Akzeptanz rein, der Bevölkerung.
Geostrategische Erwägungen.
Geostrategische Erwägungen, auch Sicherheitserwägungen. Ist das dann sicher, wenn der Strom über so große Entfernungen kommt und aus welcher Region kommt er da? Und das macht das alles etwas schwieriger. Nicht auf dem technischen Niveau, sondern eben auf dem politischen, sozialen Niveau. Es ist eine komplexe Aufgabe. Letztendlich ist der Grund für diese langen Strecken-Importe die Qualität der Energie. So eine 3000 km lange Leitung wird man nur bauen, wenn man Energie zu einer Qualität bekommt, die man vor Ort nicht bekommt.
Also Qualität im Sinne von...
Flexibilität, Verfügbarkeit nach Bedarf und gleichzeitig eben umweltfreundlich. Das ist eben das, was dieser Wüstenstrom kann. Wir selber in Europa oder auch in Deutschland haben auch regelbare, erneuerbare Energiequellen wie die Biomasse. Aber dann wird es schon ein bisschen eng. Was haben wir hier, was noch wirklich flexibel ist? Die Wasserkraft ist es nicht. Das ist bei uns hauptsächlich Laufwasserkraft.
Die Windenergie ist es auch, nur in einer sehr eingeschränkten Masse.
Windenergie und Photovoltaik sind nach unten regelbar, aber nicht dann wieder nach oben. Unbedingt dann, wenn man sie braucht. Das heißt, diese Qualität erneuerbar und gleichzeitig flexibel und gleichzeitig gesicherte Leistung, das ist eben das, was diesen Wüstenstrom-Import-Wert macht. Und deswegen kommt er auch bei uns in den Szenarien mit rein.
Wird denn dieser Wert allgemein anerkannt? Also ist das in dieser ganzen Debatte so, dass eigentlich alle so ein bisschen mit dem Kopf nicken und sagen, ja, müsste man mal machen oder ist das umstritten?
Das ist stark umstritten. Also es gibt sehr viele, die meinen, dass man die Schwankungen, die wir hier erzeugen mit erneuerbaren Energien wunderbar durch Verstärkung der Netze ausgleichen kann, dass wir genügend Speicherkapazitäten haben in Europa, dass wir das nicht unbedingt brauchen. Wenn sich das so erweist, ist das auch sinnvoll, weil man durch Europa nicht unbedingt eine 3000 km lange Leitung bauen muss. Diese wird man wirklich nur bauen, wenn man die Qualität, die man dadurch bekommt, nicht selbst irgendwie erzeugen kann.
Und das ist noch offen?
Das ist, ich sage mal, kontrovers diskutiert. Ich habe da schon meine eigene Meinung dazu, aber die wird nicht von allen geteilt. Und das ist ja auch gut so, weil das kann sich jeder erinnern und das kann auch anders kommen. Nur ich habe diese Ressourcen an Speichern und die Möglichkeit, das Netz derart zu verstärken, um dann wirklich bis zu 80%, 90% oder vielleicht auch mal 100% erneuerbare Energie zu kommen, bei uns noch nicht entdecken können. Also da denke ich, ist das Szenario, was wir gebaut haben, in sich konsistent, als es nicht irgendwelche technischen Durchbrüche erfordert, die es heute noch nicht gibt und die heute auch noch nicht sichtbar sind. Wenn so technische Durchbrüche kommen sollten, ist das ja wunderbar. Dann kann man auf das eine oder andere verzichten. Aber das Szenario, was wir gebaut haben, kommt eben ohne nennenswerte zusätzliche Speicherkapazitäten, die nicht sichtbar sind in Europa aus. Und es kommt auch ohne eine Verzehnfachung unserer Netze, unserer Transportnetze aus. Das ist dafür nicht notwendig, weil da hatten wir Zweifel. Das wäre sozusagen gegen die Sicherheitsvorgabe unserer Zielfunktion gegangen, wenn wir solche Unsicherheiten eingebaut hätten. Was wir sagen können, es geht auch ohne. Man muss nicht unbedingt speichern, man muss nicht unbedingt große Mengen. Also unser Netz auf große Kapazitäten ausbauen, wenn man so eine DESERTEC-Stromimport-Alternative oder ein zusätzliches Element mit einbaut. Das ist die Aussage. Wenn man das dann trotzdem hinkriegt, dann kann man vielleicht darauf verzichten. Dann stellt sich allerdings noch die Frage, warum man unbedingt darauf verzichten will. Ich denke, auch aus sozialen Gründen hat so eine Zusammenarbeit und so einen Zusammenschluss mit der nordafrikanischen Region eine ganz große politische Bedeutung für Europa. Weil uns davon autonom machen oder abzuschotten, würde heißen... Ja, was heißt das eigentlich? Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen, was das heißen würde und was das für Konsequenzen hätte, wenn wir jetzt versuchen würden, uns von dieser Region abzunabeln. Das Mittelmeer ist keine Grenze, sondern ist eine Verbindung, immer schon gewesen. Und ich denke, so ein Zusammenschluss dieser beiden Regionen, um gemeinsam die verfügbaren Ressourcen optimal zu nutzen, die da verfügbar sind, das ist für einen wesentlich besseren Weg, als uns da abzunabeln.
Ja, ich meine, es gab ja viel Bewegung. Ich will das jetzt hier auch gar nicht auf so einer politischen Ebene diskutieren, aber es ist ja auch offensichtlich, dass dort viel Bewegung ist. In meinem Land mehr oder weniger. Wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, dass man dort eben große Kraftwerke aufbaut, dann wäre es ja auch so, dass die Energie, die dort erzeugt wird, nicht zu 100 Prozent dann nach Europa geleitet wird, sondern es wäre ja auch so, dass diese Energie vor allem vor Ort genutzt wird und auch dort genau dieselben Anforderungen erst mal erfüllt, wie es auch für Europa tun würde.
Ja, natürlich. Also der Stromverbrauch in der Region Nordafrika wächst mit 5 bis 8 Prozent pro Jahr. Da geht es erstmal vorrangig darum. Nach unseren Szenarien ist im Jahr 2050 dort unten etwa der gleiche Stromverbrauch wie bei uns. Ich sage immer auf Lapsich, da wächst ein zweites Europa heran in Sachen Energieverbrauch. Und auch in Sachen Bevölkerung. Die Bevölkerung ist dort unten zurzeit halb so groß wie bei uns. Und bis 2050 wird sie ungefähr genauso groß sein wie in Europa.
Da unten heißt jetzt der nordafrikanische Ring ums Mittelmeer herum?
Nordafrika, mittlere Osten und die arabische Halbinsel. Das sind so 300 Millionen Menschen. Und 2050 laut UN etwa 600 Millionen Menschen. Und das sind auch in Europa 600 Millionen Menschen werden es dann aber auch immer noch sein. Also wir wachsen da nicht in der Bevölkerung. Die Wirtschaft da unten wächst sehr stark. Auch hohe Wirtschaftswachstumsraten. Bei uns ist sie eher wächst sie geringer, auf hohem Niveau natürlich. Und das heißt auch wirtschaftlich wird die Region da unten etwa auf unsere heutige Größenordnung und Leistungsfähigkeit kommen. Und letztendlich eben auch energetisch. Also in all diesen drei Punkten Bevölkerung, Wirtschaft und Energie wächst da ein zweites Europa heran. Und ich stelle dann immer die Frage, wer kriegt denn dann im Jahr 2050 die Energie? Vor allem die fossile Energie. Und es ist klar, dass sich hier, wenn wir da nicht auf eine gemeinsame nachhaltige Versorgung umschalten, dass sich da Konflikte abzeichnen.
Weil es natürlich die Staaten dann aus ihrem eigenen Fundus noch am ehesten selbst versorgen werden.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Natürlich müssen sie auch. Und die Philosophie dahinter ist letztendlich, diese ideal gespeicherten fossilen Energieformen so weit runterzufahren, dass sie eben dafür, die Lücken zu stopfen, die Erneuerbare nicht stopfen können, noch lange, lange Zeit ausreichen. Das ist letztendlich die Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie. Aber nicht Kohle, Öl und Gas in der Grundlast verbrennen. In der ungeregelten Grundlast. Das ist eine Verschwendung ohne Ende. Sondern sie genau dafür nutzen, wo sie wirklich gut geeignet sind, als ideal gespeicherte Lückenfüller für die Verbrauchsspitzen. Und die erneuerbaren Ströme so weit nutzen, wie sie verfügbar sind. Die haben ihre Grenzen, ist ganz klar. Die kosten auch Geld. Aber letztendlich wird daraus ein nachhaltiges Konzept.
Wenn wir noch mal vielleicht einen Zacken konkreter. Es gibt da ja sicherlich schon sehr ausgereifte Planspiele, was man jetzt auch mal konkret bauen könnte. Sagen wir mal, irgendjemand schnippst jetzt mit dem Finger und die ganzen politischen Probleme sind weitgehend gelöst. Ja, alle haben sich lieb und warten auf das Kabel. Was könnte man denn jetzt zum Bauen? Was würde denn jetzt aus heutiger Sicht mit den ganzen technischen Realisierungsoptionen, die ja schon klar zu sein scheinen, was würde man konkret bauen wollen?
Ja, man würde das weiterbauen, was es schon gibt. Eine Verbindung zwischen Marokko und Spanien zum Beispiel, die gibt es schon. Die hat jetzt 1 Gigawatt Leistung, kann auf 2 Gigawatt ausgebaut werden und man könnte eben genau da über die geografische Region noch weitere Verbindungen schaffen. Auch weiter als bis Spanien, dann eben bis Frankreich oder sogar bis Deutschland. Da müsste man Kabel legen halt dann. Das nächste ist die geplante Verbindung zwischen Tunesien und Italien. Die ist geplant, die wird auch wahrscheinlich gebaut demnächst, findet schon statt. Und dann ist hintenrum noch über Türkei letztendlich, Libanon, Syrien ist da dazwischen, da ist natürlich ein Flock noch drin. Und da könnte man auch eine Verbindung schaffen nach Nordafrika.
Oder halt über Zypern wäre ja auch möglich.
Zypern, ja, es gibt mannigfaltige Verbindungen. Auch Algerien, Spanien ist eine Trasse geplant, durchs Mittelmeer dann durchzulegen. Das heißt, diese Verbindungen finden schon statt, auch mit HGÜ-Technologie. Die sind in der Planung letztendlich vorrangig, um Ausgleichseffekte zu ermöglichen zwischen den Ländern.
Aber gibt es denn im Süden schon Kraftwerke, die diese Leitung bedienen können? Oder ist das jetzt erst mal nur die Infrastruktur, so für den Fall das?
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist erst mal nur so, um die Länder miteinander zu verbinden, um ein gemeinsames Netz zu schaffen. Letztendlich, was den Solarstromimport angeht, da muss man dann Kraftwerke bauen, die wirklich Regelenergie für den Bedarf in Deutschland zum Beispiel oder in Spanien liefern. Also, wo diese Qualität der Stromerzeugung in einem konkreten Kraftwerk geplant und gebaut wird und realisiert wird und dann über eine Leitung von A nach B in Deutschland eingespeist wird, nach Bedarf in Deutschland. Das ist nicht das Kraftwerk, was gleichzeitig für Marokko arbeitet. Das muss daneben stehen und für Marokko arbeiten und dort denselben Zweck erfüllen, nämlich Regelenergie für Marokko liefern. Das sind zwei verschiedene Kraftwerke.
Warum nicht eins für alle?
Ja, weil wenn dann mal die Situation kommt, dass Deutschland eine Stromlücke hat und diesen Strom dringend braucht und bereit ist, beliebig viel Geld dafür zu bezahlen, dann gehen in Marokko möglicherweise die Lichter aus. Vor allem, weil Deutschland 80 Gigawatt absaugt und Marokko sechs.
Okay, verstehe. Man würde sich schon sein eigenes Kraftwerk bauen wollen und dann einfach auch die Versorgungssicherheit an der Stelle zu haben.
Es spricht nichts dagegen, diese zu verbinden sozusagen. Also irgendwie über eine Technologie, dass wenn man mal jetzt da Überschüsse erzeugt, also Deutschland fordert jetzt nichts ab, ich müsste jetzt, sagen wir mal, Energie wegschmeißen aus dem Solarkraftwerk oder aus dem Windpark, weil ich es nicht nach Deutschland liefern kann, dann hätte ich das für Marokko zur Verfügung. Also so weit muss man die Trennung nicht treiben, dass man das jetzt nicht realisieren könnte. Aber es müssen da sehr klare Regeln geschaffen werden, wer im Zweifelsfall den Strom kriegt, sage ich mal. Weil sonst saugt der Stärkere einfach den Strom ab. Und das wäre natürlich auch nicht gut für die relativ kleinen Verbraucher da unten.
Wie findet man denn jetzt so einen optimalen Standort? Wir haben gesagt, okay, da ist viel Platz. Viel Platz heißt auch viele Optionen. Ist alles gleich gut geeignet? Ist das jetzt nur die Frage, ist da eine Wanderdüne oder nicht? Oder sind auch in dem Bereich noch die möglichen Energiegewinnungen noch sehr unterschiedlich? Wie kommt man da zur Platzwahl?
Das erste ist die Ressource, die Solarstrahlung. Die Solarstrahlung, da kommt die Raumfahrt wieder ins Spiel. Da benutzen wir die Satelliten-Fernerkundung dafür. Auch unsere Kollegen aus Oberpfaffenhofen, die uns Daten dafür liefern. Wo sind wie viel Wolken? Wo sind wie viel Aerosole in der Atmosphäre? Also Staub zum Beispiel, dann Wasserdampf und so weiter. Die Komponenten der Atmosphäre bestimmt man praktisch aus der Fernerkundung, baut sich damit eine Modellatmosphäre zusammen und ermittelt dann über ein sehr anspruchsvolles Modell, was wir hier haben, die Solarstrahlung am Boden. Daraus kann man dann sozusagen im stundenweisen Rhythmus ausrechnen, was so ein Solarkraftwerk oder eine Photovoltaikzelle an Leistung generieren kann.
Das könnte man machen oder ist auch getan worden? War das jetzt auch schon Teil dieser Studie oder hat das damit erstmal nichts zu tun?
Doch, das Fernerkundungssystem wurde auch in der Studie schon benutzt. Wir haben da eine Karte der Solarnstrahlungsressource für den Mittelmeerraum generiert im Rahmen der Studie.
Und was hat man da so herauslesen können?
Naja, das Triviale, dass dort unten sehr viel mehr Sonnenenergie zur Verfügung ist. Über das Jahr ist es ungefähr dreimal so viel wie bei uns. Und dass die Energie vor allem sehr viel regelmäßiger verfügbar ist.
Ich meine jetzt nicht so sehr im Vergleich zu Europa, sondern im Vergleich zu allen sich im Wesentlichen anbietenden Gebieten. Ich meine, das ist ja auch eine riesige Region. Das ist ja nochmal genauso breit wie Europa.
Naja, man kann ganz einfach sagen, da wo die Wüste ist, ist die Sonnenenergie natürlich sehr stark vorhanden. Deswegen ist die Wüste da. Und das zeigt wieder, die Sonnenenergie ist über alle diese Länder sehr gleichmäßig verteilt.
Also eigentlich würde alles in Frage kommen?
Es kommt jedes Land in Frage. Und innerhalb des Landes gibt es natürlich Unterschiede. Zum Beispiel nördlich an der Küste ist weniger Sonnenenergie im Mittelmeer. Wenn man weiter in die Wüste geht, wird es mehr. Wenn man dann noch weiter in die Wüste geht, wird es wieder weniger, weil dann sehr viel Aerosole und Sand und so in Staubtauchchen in der Wüste sind. Da gibt es auch so ein bisschen optimale Bereiche. Am Roten Meer entlang ist es eine sehr, sehr gute Situation. Da haben sie wunderbare Einstrahlung. Deswegen sind da auch lauter Badeorte, nehme ich an.
Ja, sind sie. Da gibt es doch so viele Badeorte, dass da gar kein Platz mehr ist für Solarthermie.
Nein, die Badeorte sind ja nur direkt am Strand. Dahinter ist noch sehr viel Platz. Und die Badeorte brauchen ja auch sehr viel Energie. Da ergibt sich tatsächlich ein ganz interessanter Markt für Sonnenenergie. Zumal die teilweise also ölgetriebene Stromerzeugung haben. Also mit sehr hohen Weltmarktpreisen jetzt heute. Also gerade da ist ein ganz interessanter Markt sogar.
Wenn man jetzt so einen... Okay, also Platzwahl ist nicht so das Problem. Ich dachte, da gibt es vielleicht noch ein paar.
Man guckt natürlich auf eine ganze Reihe von Auswahlkriterien. Also einfach Risiken zum Beispiel, also Sturmgefahr, Hagelgefahr. Das ist aber auch alles dokumentiert. Also da gibt es auch Karten.
Hagelgefahr?
Hagelgefahr, ja. Die Münchner Rückversicherungsgesellschaft hat einen Atlas der Natur gefahren, weltweit, indem man gucken kann, wo welche Gefahren drohen.
Ist Hagel in der Wüste?
Ist Hagel in der Wüste, ja. In Kairo gab es mal Tennisballgroße Hagelkörner. Das richtet natürlich einen Schaden an.
Ist das auch für Solarpanele?
Tennisballgroße ist nicht mehr gut. In Kalifornien gab es bei den Anlagen schon mal taubeneigroße Hagelkörner. Da wurden die Kollektoren in die Schutzposition gefahren. Die haben hinten eine sehr stabile Lackschicht drauf, die sie erstens von der Atmosphäre abkapselt, den Spiegel abkapselt und dann zweitens auch einen mechanischen Schutz bietet. Da ist nichts passiert, aber Tennisball groß ist klar. Das würde reinhauen. Aber solche Events sind sehr lokal.
Aber sowas würde man auch vorsehen. Man würde sowas schon so bauen?
Na ja, in Maßen. Man kann die Risiken bestimmen, sozusagen. Aber wenn ein sowas trifft, dann hilft wirklich nur noch die Versicherung. Aber da gibt es eben bestimmte Risiken, die man praktisch abschätzen muss und quantifizieren muss. Es hagelt ja nicht ständig, denn es sind große Hagelkörner in der Wüste.
Aber das sind so Aspekte, die man jetzt nicht unbedingt als erstes bedenken würde.
Nee, was häufiger vorkommt, sind Sandstürme. Aber auch die Regionen sind ja bekannt. Wo die häufig vorkommen, da bleibt man auch weg. Allein weil eben die Atmosphäre da auch trüb ist in der Regel. Da gibt es dann ständig Wind und dann bleibt man auch da weg. Man sucht sich eben die Regionen, die wirklich sehr gute Einstrahlung bieten, die auch erreichbar sind, Straßennetz, Infrastruktur für die Stromanbindung. Man will ja auch jetzt nicht gleich, wenn man jetzt Cairo versorgen will, Tausende Kilometer Leitung bauen und so. Und das sind immer die Kompromisse. Dann eben Naturschutzgebiete, Landwirtschaft geht vor. Wir haben da auch eine Analyse gemacht mit dem geografischen Informationssystem. Also alle landwirtschaftlichen Flächen in Nordafrika erst mal ausgeschlossen, weil die Landwirtschaft natürlich Vorrang vor Sonnenenergie hat, würde ich mal sagen. Und es gibt auch genügend andere Flächen, die man da nutzen kann.
Was würde man denn dann konkret bauen? Also solathermische Anlagen, klar, das hatten wir ja eingangs schon erwähnt. Das ist das, was sich da anbaut. Aber wie groß muss man sich das jetzt vorstellen? Ich meine, wir reden ja die ganze Zeit von enormen Kapazitäten, die dort produziert werden sollen, damit eben auch da Europa signifikant von außen so eine Energieinjektion erhält, die dann eine große Batterie von anderen Kraftwerken obsolet macht. Wie groß muss so etwas sein? Also reden wir da von städtegroßen Spiegelfeldern, wo in der Mitte so ein Kochtopf von der Größe Manhattens steht, vor sich hin blubbert oder übertreibe ich jetzt?
Ja, also gebaut wird ein, wir nennen das ein ausgewogener Mix aus verschiedenen erneuerbaren Energietechnologien, die sich auch unterschiedlich zusammensetzen werden, je nach Land, je nach Verfügbarkeit. In der Wüste vor allem Windparks und Sonnenenergie. Weil der Strombedarf so stark wächst in der Region, werden solarthermische Kraftwerke sehr stark gebaut werden müssen, weil nur diese eben diese gesicherte Leistung auch liefern können, die gebraucht wird, um einen steigenden Strombedarf abdecken zu können. Aber eben auch, wie gesagt, alle anderen Technologien, die lokal dann zur Verfügung stehen. Dadurch, dass der Strombedarf in dieser Region bis 2050 auf etwa unser Niveau anwachsen wird, werden die Länder dort unten etwa 15% ihrer Energie exportieren zu uns. Und wir werden etwa 15% unseres Stroms importieren. Das ist tatsächlich auch wieder die gleiche Zahl, weil die eben auf unser Verbrauchsniveau angewachsen sind. Das ist von der Energie, die wir im Jahr verbrauchen, 15%, von der Leistung, die diese Kraftwerke liefern, etwa 7%, etwa die Hälfte. Das liegt an der höheren Auslastung dieser Kraftwerke, weil die eben mit Speicher auch bis zu 5.000, 6.000 Stunden im Jahr arbeiten werden, um bei uns die Regelenergie zu liefern. Also diese 15% Energie, 7% Leistung relativieren das Ganze schon mal ein bisschen. Es wird ja immer von diesem riesigen Projekt gesprochen. Es ist nicht ein Projekt, es sind viele einzelne Kraftwerke, die von verschiedenen Konsortien in völlig verschiedenen Ländern rund ums Mittelmeer gebaut werden, auch unabhängig voneinander. Das wird auch nicht unbedingt koordiniert stattfinden, sondern nach Bedarf. Also wenn ein Land den Bedarf für solche flexible Solarenergie hat, wird es den anmelden und sich einen Lieferanten suchen. Und das nächste Land wird das auch tun, vielleicht mit einem anderen Lieferanten. Also so, so denke ich, wird das stattfinden.
Aber wie groß muss man sich jetzt so eine solarthermische Anlage, die ja, würde ich sagen, jetzt so im Wesentlichen die Oblast trägt?
Man kann sich das jetzt schon mal angucken in Spanien. Da steht ein 50 Megawatt-Kraftwerk an der Soll, mehrere davon sogar, das mit einem 7-Stunden-Speicher ausgerüstet ist, also 7 Stunden nachts auch Volllast betrieben werden kann und deswegen ein doppelt so großes Solarfeld hat, als es bräuchte, wenn es nur tagsüber laufen würde. Und das Ding hat für 50 Megawatt 2 Quadratkilometer Fläche beansprucht sozusagen. Das ist schon ein Mordsding. Das ist schon groß. Das Witzige ist, es gibt Kollegen in der Forschungsgemeinschaft, die haben jetzt eine Lebenszyklusanalyse des Landbedarfs gemacht für verschiedene Energietechnologien. Also Windparks, Wasserkraft, Kohlekraftwerke, Gasturbinen, Solarkraftwerke, Photovoltaik. Und da stellt sich heraus, dass die Sonnenenergie mit einer der kompaktesten vom Landflächenbedarf her Stromerzeugungstechnologien ist. Also die ist ungefähr in der Größenordnung eines Kohlekraftwerks heute, eines modernen Kohlekraftwerks, wenn man die gesamte Infrastruktur über die Lebensdauer des Kraftwerks mit berücksichtigt. Bei Kohle ist das halt nicht das Kraftwerk, sondern das ist das Bergwerk und die Infrastruktur, Transport und so weiter und so weiter. Und wenn man da schaut, ist der Footprint etwa von solchen Solarkraftwerken in der Größe von heutigen Kohlekraftwerken.
Das heißt, dieser Blick auf Solarthermie, wo man sich mal denkt, so Unmengen an Flächen müssten jetzt geopfert werden für diese Energie, stimmt so eigentlich gar nicht.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht, sondern es stellt sich als sehr kompakte Technologie heraus, mit einem geringen Footprint. Und vor allem die Qualität dieses Footprints ist natürlich eine ganz andere. Jetzt vergleichen Sie mal einen Braunkohlebergbau mit dem Solarfeld, das Sie nach 20 Jahren wieder abbauen können, wenn Sie möchten. Das in der Wüste Schatten erzeugt. Wir haben in Spanien festgestellt, bei den Linea Fresnel Kollektoren, das ist eine bestimmte Technologie, dass das Gras unter den Kollektoren grüner ist als außenrum. Das hat sogar Vorteile letztendlich. Die Leute denken darüber nach, ob sie da unten Landwirtschaft betreiben können zwischen den Kollektoren, weil da Sachen wachsen, die in der Wüste nicht wachsen würden. So etwas wird da ernsthaft nachgedacht.
Das heißt, man würde die auch bewusst höher bauen?
Man würde die eventuell höher bauen, anpassen, vielleicht sogar so regeln, dass genügend Sonnenenergie für die Kartoffeln dann da ist, aber auch noch genügend für den Strom. Das kann man alles optimieren. Da denken Leute drüber nach. Das heißt, diese Qualität des Flächenverbrauchs ist völlig andere. Bei allen erneuerbaren Energien. Also wenn Windrad irgendwo auf einer Weide steht, ist natürlich eine sehr große Fläche irgendwie beansprucht.
Na gut, für den Ackerbau bräuchte man natürlich dann auch noch Wasser. Aber dann hätte man auch gleich die Energie, das Wasser dort auch hin zu bringen.
Wenn man das in der Wüste machen will, ja. Da hätte man dann... Na ja, man muss sich mal die nordafrikanische Region anschauen. Die ist umgeben von Wasser. Riesige Landflächen umgeben von Wasser. Nur das Wasser ist halt salzig. Das ist Meerwasser. Aber die Energie ist ja da, die ist im Überfluss da. Deswegen ist da eine Wüste. Und wenn man diese Energie jetzt für die Wasserinsalzungen nutzen würde, was auch geht, technisch ist das kein Problem.
Was auch schon getan wird. Also es gibt ja auch in der Region bereits mehr Insalzungsanlagen, oder gibt es die?
Ja, die werden halt mit Öl und Gas betrieben und nicht mit Sonnenenergie. Aber der Schritt ist auch kein großer im Prinzip. Wir reden ja die ganze Zeit davon, Öl, Gas und Kohle durch Sonnenenergie zu ersetzen. Letztendlich ist genau das das. Und dann hätte man eine nachhaltige Energiequelle auch für die Meerwasserinsalzungen, die nötig ist. Also die haben da ein sehr starkes wachsendes Wasserproblem. Das ist fast dringender als das Energieproblem da unten. Und hier hätte man eine Möglichkeit, so etwas nachhaltig zu gestalten. Und auch ökonomisch, ökologisch verträglich letztendlich.
Die Meere leiden jetzt nicht besonders darunter, dass man ihnen etwas Wasser und Salz entzieht?
Nein, weil das Wasser verdampft irgendwann wieder und regnet dann wieder ab über den Meeren. Also da passiert nicht viel. Und es sind letztendlich nicht die großen Mengen, die dann da...
Es hat ja immer alles irgendwelche Auswirkungen, an die man vorher nicht denkt. Deswegen frage ich lieber gleich mal.
Lokal hat die Wasserentsalzung teilweise schon sehr starke Auswirkungen. Man muss aufpassen, wo man jetzt die angedickte Salzlösung... Also man holt ja destilliertes Wasser raus und hat da auf der anderen Seite aber eine dickere Salzlösung, eine stärkere Salzlösung und die muss man natürlich so einspeisen wieder ins Wasser, damit da nicht lokale Spezies zugrunde gehen. Das ist aber immer so bei Wasserentsalzungen, da muss man darauf achten. Das kostet in der Regel auch Energie, das umweltfreundlich zu gestalten.
Muss denn das Salz unbedingt zurückgeführt werden? Könnte man das nicht auch als Salz verwenden?
Ja, kann man auch letztendlich. Man könnte es letztendlich mit so einer Energie verdampfen lassen, das restliche Wasser und dann wirklich das kristallisierte Salz ernten. Auch das wird gemacht und ist auch angedacht. Je nach Lokalität wird man verschiedene Lösungen dann dafür finden. Letztendlich kostet diese Sache immer, dass die Entsalzung umweltfreundlich zu gestalten kostet Energie. Das wird in der Regel nicht gemacht, weil die Energie aus fossilen Brennstoffen kommt.
Aber in dem Moment, wo man ohnehin Solarthermie, Kraftwerk hätte, wäre das dann auch...
Dann kostet es noch Geld. Aber es führt zu nachhaltigen Lösungen letztendlich. Das Ganze ist dann wieder als Investition zu sehen. Und letztendlich hat es Vorteile, auch wirtschaftlicher Art.
Klingt alles so ein bisschen wie nach dem Heiligen Gral. Wo ist denn der Haken?
Ja, das ist das Hauptgegenargument. Es ist zu schön, um wahr zu sein. Das ist genau das Gegenargument, was ich immer höre. Und damit ist die Diskussion in der Regel beendet, weil dagegen kann ich nichts antworten. Es gibt jede Menge technische und vor allem eben, wie gesagt, die politischen Herausforderungen, die dazu überwinden sind. Aber genau dieses, es ist zu schön, um wahr zu sein, ist immer das Haupt... Ich glaube, es ist einer der Hauptgründe, warum so wenig passiert in der Richtung. Weil die Leute lieber... Also sie akzeptieren irgendwas, wo man in einen sauren Apfel beißen muss, wo man ein Risiko eingehen muss, wo einem vielleicht dann mal eine Tsunami, so ein Atomkraftwerk um die Ohren haut. Das akzeptieren sie eher. Ja, wir müssen das leider. Etwas, was so gut klingt, glauben sie nicht. Das ist tatsächlich...
Ja, weil Probleme haben wir immer gehabt. Was soll denn das jetzt hier problemfrei in die Zukunft?
Das haben wir nicht gewohnt. Wenn mir mal was einfällt, dann werde ich das sofort publizieren, damit dieses sozusagen bedient wird.
So hier, wir haben jetzt auch ein Problem.
Ach ja, genau.
Gott sei Dank.
Nein, es gibt natürlich Probleme auch. Aber das Hauptproblem ist nicht der frühe Entwicklungsstand. Wir haben ein Gigawatt. Die anderen Technologien sind inzwischen bei 70 und 250. Wir haben die Konkurrenz der anderen erneuerbaren Technologien, die durch diesen starken Ausbau inzwischen günstiger geworden sind. Mit der Solathämie haben wir dieses Problem. Und wir haben natürlich jede Menge Konkurrenz auf Seiten des konventionellen Lagers, also Kernenergie und fossile Energieträger. Die wollen ja sowas gar nicht haben. Die beanspruchen, dass nur sie allein Regelnergie liefern können. Viele Leute glauben nicht, dass aus Sonnenergie Regelnergie werden kann über so ein Konzept. Das ist auch noch nicht so bekannt.
Wir hatten ja jetzt in Deutschland 2011 einschneidende Änderungen. Viele Atomkraftwerke sind vom Netz genommen worden. In der Folge der Ereignisse in Fukushima, wie er allgemein bekannt ist. Es war ja immer so eine generelle Sicht der Dinge, dass genau dieser Fall ja ein großes Problem wäre, weil eben dann in dem Moment nicht mehr diese Regelnergie so zuverlässig geliefert werden können soll. Ich weiß jetzt, habe jetzt nicht den Einblick, ob es tatsächlich zu irgendwelchen Engpässen konkret gekommen ist oder die eben nur wiederum durch die Zuführung anderer Atomenergie aus anderen Ländern hat ausgeglichen werden können. Wie entwickelt sich denn das so real unter diesen Bedingungen?
Ja, es geht eben dann doch. Also in Japan weiß ich es nicht. Da kann es sein, dass sie einfach auf fossile Energieträger zurückgreifen mussten, um diese Energie zu ersetzen. Weil einfach Japan bis dahin noch nicht viel erneuerbare ausgebaut hatte. In Deutschland ist es so, wir haben seit zehn Jahren massiv erneuerbare Energien zugebaut. Und wir sehen, was hier passiert. Wir sehen, dass das EEG letztendlich ein preisstabilisierendes Element unserer Stromversorgung geworden ist. Wir sehen letztendlich, dass...
Also das Erneuerbare-Energien-Gesetz.
Das Erneuerbare-Energien-Gesetz. Energie erzeugt hat, die eben preistabil ist, während das andere sich wirklich stark verteuert hat. Das kann man sehr schön aus den Statistiken ablesen. Und sich weiter verteuern wird, voraussichtlich. Auch was eben Analysten sagen. Wir sehen, dass letztendlich unter bestimmten Wetterlagen in Frankreich die Atomkraftwerke in die Knie gehen und Deutschland lustig Energie nach Frankreich exportiert. Nach Abschaltung unserer Kernreaktoren. Das hat man in den letzten Wochen. Also das ist eben nicht so. Der Punkt ist, dass erneuerbare Energien, wenn alle Formen erneuerbarer Energie genutzt werden, dass damit Strom nach Bedarf erzeugt werden kann. Der Fehler ist zu denken, die Photovoltaik muss es allein machen. Da haben wir ein Riesenproblem.
Oder nur die Windenergie etc.
Die Windenergie muss es allein machen. Und dann sagt man, die kann es nicht, die kann es nicht. Aha, die erneuerbaren können nichts. Und der solarthermischen Kraftwerkstechnik, die man ja erst noch aus 3000 km Entfernung importieren muss, der glaubt man das eh nicht. Und das bisschen Biomasse und Wasserkraft, was wir haben, reicht nicht aus. Und schon haben wir alle ad acta gelegt und uns auf den Holzweg begeben.
Ja, machen das so, wie wir es immer gemacht haben.
Und das ist eben falsch. Alle Erneuerbaren zusammen können Energie nach Bedarf liefern. Und da muss man hin. Und zwar gemeinsam. Und nicht nur gemeinsam in Deutschland, sondern gemeinsam in Europa. Und gemeinsam in EUMENA nennen wir das. Also Europa, Mittlerer Osten, Nordafrika. Und das ist eigentlich mal eine schöne Vision. Also wenn ich dran denke, wie die Montanunion entstanden ist und aus Europa eine EU gemacht hat, dann könnte man aus EUMENA vielleicht auch mal was machen.
Sodass dieser Energieverbund vielleicht eben auch zu einer Stabilität der Gesamtregionen führen könnte. Einfach weil die Abhängigkeiten dann auch einfach klarer sind.
Genau, also die Montanunion war ein Verbund für Stahl und Kohle. Und jetzt hätten wir hier einfach Energie und Wasser zum Beispiel. Und das ist eine Vision, die mir sehr gut gefällt. Jetzt rein persönlich. Und ich denke, das ist ein Pfad in der Nachhaltigkeit. Nicht die Abschottung verschiedener Regionen voneinander. Das macht keinen Sinn. Wenn da jetzt Probleme aufgetreten sind, dann sind die lösbar. Und letztendlich eine Demokratisierung der Region ist ja nichts, was uns letztendlich entgegensteht oder was auch so einem Konzept entgegensteht, sondern im Gegenteil neue Wege für solche Konzepte öffnet. Das ist letztendlich positiv, muss man schon sagen. Viele sehen da jetzt eine Gefahr, aber ich sehe sie eigentlich nicht. Und dann gibt es noch den Hinweis, man könnte ja diese Stromleitungen dann abschalten und dann stehen wir ohne Strom da. Erstens sind sieben Prozent unserer Leistung, wie gesagt. Die sieben Prozent haben wir sowieso als Reserve. Wir haben immer mindestens 20 Prozent Reserve rumstehen, einfach weil auch was anderes passieren kann. Das heißt, die wird man ersetzen können. Und das andere ist, wir haben jetzt nur wenige Lieferanten von Energie. Wir hängen an Monopolen, die uns beliebig die Preise diktieren. Wenn jetzt hier 30 neue Lieferanten über Stromleitungen Energie nach Europa schicken, dann vervielfältigt sich unser Angebot, was in der Regel dazu führt, dass sich die Versorgungssicherheit verbessert und die Preise sinken.
ZB stabil bleiben.
Zumindest stabil bleiben, ja. Das sind stabilisierende Elemente in Versachen Sicherheit, Ökonomie. Es ist eben nicht so, dass eine Abschottung letztendlich zu einer erhöhten Sicherheit führen würde, sondern ganz das Gegenteil. Das ist im Technischen so und auch im politischen und sozialen Bereich.
Ja, ein doch sehr weitreichendes Forschungsgebiet, das hier im DLR-Standort ausgearbeitet wird, haben wir jetzt noch irgendeinen wichtigen Aspekt vernachlässigt in dieser doch weitgeführten Debatte.
Ich müsste mir noch mal anhören, um vielleicht noch rauszufinden, was noch fehlt.
Das können wir ja machen, dann können wir jetzt noch einen zweiten Teil nachliefern. Ansonsten würde ich sagen, vielen Dank, Franz Triebke, für die Ausführungen hier zu dem gesamten Themenkomplex Erneuerbare Energien und überhaupt Energiewirtschaft von morgen, an dem hier gearbeitet wird beim DLR. Ja, und ich sage danke fürs Zuhören hier in der 33. Ausgabe von Raumzeit. Und wie immer, es geht hier bald wieder weiter.